um
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
well i told you last time i was looking
for like i was like well i was looking
for footage of a train derailing
but i was like well that might be a
little tacky like i cared about that
like before but when i first when i
first heard that
i thought it was going to be something
like from [ __ ] good the bad the ugly
oh yeah i could have done
or a [ __ ] high plains drifter it's a
work in progress okay yeah remember the
one where the guys are driving down the
street and the [ __ ] car comes at him
[ __ ] through the air
and lands into the [ __ ]
uh into the lane right in front of him
yeah i showed you yeah that's the
[ __ ] trip too yeah that kind of
reminded me of that
sandra's name is jesus says don't touch
yourself yeah
we have a hold on
[Laughter]
yeah
okay the cockroaches are out people go
ahead and get rid of them look at him
somebody somebody get the raid get the
rage
yeah i don't have time to [ __ ] do all
that i don't either and i don't
particularly i don't really care all
that much it's too much effort
it's too much effort to like put my
finger on the mouth yeah to be honest
with you
but yeah so hey everybody it's wednesday
i've already got like half a drink down
so you know yeah
i was sleepy today i don't know what the
[ __ ] deal was i don't know either
cause you know got plenty of sleep last
night yeah i thought you did so what
what is on the agenda for today
i don't know there's never anything on
the agenda for sidetracks so sondra's
here where the hell where the hell's
tila we haven't seen tila in a while
that's true she didn't show up anymore
she's running off with he-man
[Laughter]
taylor's he-man's girlfriend that's
right a program yeah t-e-e elena i had
totally forgotten about that her mom
must have been a fan of the show
yeah yeah i just yeah we were watching
like i remember last uh last time that i
mentioned we were re-watching uh the
toys that made us and so i think we only
had like three episodes left i wasn't
watching an order
so i watched the star wars toys one i
watched the
um what was the other one i watched the
gi joe one
and then i watched the
whatever the other one was yeah
tim is in there too okay yeah
jesus jesus says don't [ __ ] touch
yourself don't [ __ ] touch yourself
don't just just says don't touch
yourself
i said that [ __ ] last time
you might have i don't really remember
how do you [ __ ] remember this [ __ ]
well she probably like writes it down
yeah i mean she's probably not as drunk
as you are so she has that going for her
yeah it's [ __ ] flares
oh my god all right so i don't know i'm
like
in a weird like place right now
yeah
i guess
keep drinking you'll go to a better
place in a minute that's true yeah
what's the best thing about drinking i
was watching
i was watching they got this guy who's
uh running around elon musk up here
interviewing him and he's showing that
construction site we got up here in
florida they put part three today and i
can't believe how fast those guys
actually work i mean they're [ __ ]
flying building towers big launch sites
building big rockets
it's not like back in the days of nasa
where it
take them a year to get something done i
mean they're [ __ ] flying through that
[ __ ]
i always wonder though the faster it
goes like you know what's the quality
like
it doesn't matter there's nobody in it
i know but he wrecks him and a couple
weeks later he's got another one
they got four or five of them rockets
sitting there just pissing money away no
it's making money i get it it's making
money no i mean pissing money away just
like not just like doing it quick and
not doing it good um no i think i think
it's good
um they're all test beds each one of
them you know it's well thought out each
one was a you know like a test in that
different functions of the rocket
whether it can launch or land and
evidently making the rocket isn't isn't
that expensive it's the facility that
builds them is what cost all the money
yeah the rocket the rocket's made out of
pretty much off the shelf stuff made out
of cheap material
[ __ ] they bought it like [ __ ]
michaels or something you know
well there's a there's a diaspora of
[ __ ] pumps and [ __ ] things that
they can make and certain some of it's
custom but a lot of it's just kind of
like off the shelf
it's pretty amazing what they're doing
it's way way ahead of what i thought
that what i thought they could do yeah
tb drugger says yo whatever happened to
time machine 13 i forgot about that till
you mentioned the toy thing yeah that
was something that was like an idea we
were throwing around like back in the
old days that we were gonna do like this
kind of like retro i think i even did
like a logo for it and maybe even an
intro that's a good idea and then we
just never really did get around to it
yeah one thing one thing led to another
we never got around to got sidetracked
just much like this show yeah
i don't know we might still do it at
some point but it does seem like i don't
know if i if we do do it we might
replace it like it might be a
replacement for like something else and
it would probably be another recorded
one and like not a live stream i would
think
but you know
dj maniac said gi joe has been my
pendant since i was six years old i've
spent more money than you can imagine
all those things
my brother had a [ __ ] ton of them i had
forgotten until i re-watched the g.i joe
show like how many [ __ ]
figures there were
i think blowtorch was my favorite
because i liked that he had like that
bright red and yellow and [ __ ] like that
on there
that they were talking about the
ridiculous [ __ ]
uh vehicles and like all the you know
because they said you know the the
figures there was a [ __ ] ton of them but
it's like they weren't that expensive
so most of their money came from the
vehicles and like the other stuff and i
didn't like they had that they showed
that big [ __ ] aircraft carrier thing
which is like more than seven feet long
yeah that you could land the actual
[ __ ]
jets on that like the little dudes could
sit in and it was just i didn't know
anybody that had enough money to buy
that [ __ ]
yeah i think they said they actually
lost money on figures didn't they
well they said it was like a loss leader
in the sense that they weren't making
any money on the figures like breaking
even i guess so but that was like trying
to spur you into like buying
buying a [ __ ] vehicle buying the
vehicles i don't even think they do they
even make g.i joes anymore i'm pretty
sure like on the show they said they
didn't make them because well they made
them for a long time like in the what
like 50s and 60s and stuff but they were
like doll sized like barbies yeah um but
then they didn't start making them again
until like the early 80s i guess they
didn't come out it didn't come out until
i was pretty much out of high school
yeah i was talking about 96 yeah like 86
87 my brother had a bunch of this stuff
but we were more into like we were more
than just like star wars toys and
kind of horror kind of stuff we had like
a lot of
we had a lot of like monster toys like
and [ __ ] where you could like make
you know that kind of [ __ ] where you
could melt
crayons and then like put them in little
molds and you can make like little bugs
and whatnot
you didn't melt crayons for that that
was like a plastic
like you know what i mean it was what
was it called the bug maker the thing
maker whatever the [ __ ] it was called
it was like this like colored
um
plasticky stuff and then you melted it
in this little thing and then you poured
it into molds and it made like little
spiders and [ __ ]
these things would still make them
they're six inches tall now oh okay
classified or something oh all right
yeah because
the
figures from before were like three and
three quarters inch although the
original gi joes were what like 12-inch
dolls or they were same size as barbie
right because that was like the idea
was that barbie was so successful they
said oh we want like a similar doll for
boys where they could like drop them up
and whatnot they came up with the idea
of the action figure even though they
were like we can't call it a doll
because that's like too girly and boys
would be like ooh girls are yucky yeah
now there can't be any crossover
they learned that with shira
although that didn't happen until later
i think you remembered
um the he-man show yeah that that was
what made the
line stop selling as much and that
wasn't what it was because the shira
[ __ ] came out like a couple years before
it started declining okay it started for
it it's it started declining because
what they did was that they produced
they started coming up with all these
new characters to like feed the market
that's right you couldn't get these but
then you couldn't get the old ones
anymore so like people that were like
just newly into the show we're like hey
i want a he-man and a skeletor you
couldn't get him because they're like
hey we have this one that farts isn't
that right so it's and and they would
like flood the market with those
and you couldn't kind of dumb you think
they'd make
the main characters just on a constant
basis i know i guess well i don't know
like i feel like back then maybe they
thought well everybody's already got the
original ones now so we have to give
them like new product all the time but i
said another thing that you have to
think is like if the cartoon is still on
then you're getting new viewers like a
certain percentage of them
every year that don't have the [ __ ] that
are just now getting into it and it's
like maybe they would like you know just
a certain percentage of the stuff you
should make like the original figures i
mean i get why
because you know
particularly with toys it's like it's
kind of like well people get bored of
this they have to get new [ __ ] all the
time i get that but
they really should have a certain
percentage
kind of set aside for the old [ __ ]
because you know
zack
i hate the fact we introduce young kids
to the idea of stds via cooties
i don't know what he's talking about get
a cootie shot well you didn't you didn't
like go through that like a little kids
but when you're a little kid like if she
girls have cooties boys have cooties you
had to have a cootie shot like in case a
boy touched you or something yeah that
didn't seem like stds though i didn't i
didn't make a collab well from an adult
standpoint it definitely seems like that
i never made that connection
i did later i did later
yeah you know what i mean i just thought
it was like fleas
catching fleas
[Music]
sorta yeah i guess so
uh terry asked tom did you see uh m
night shyamalan's new film old yet and
if so what'd you think of it i didn't
see it we haven't seen it yet i've heard
like really mixed reviews most i have to
say i don't watch a lot of reviews but
just from like scanning across like the
titles and stuff um of some articles and
videos about it it does seem like 80
85 of the reviews seem really negative
um but i don't know like i said
i'll probably i don't know if i'd go to
the theater and see it but i'll probably
like see it when it's
not
expensive
[Laughter]
once you make why don't you make sandra
a uh a moderator we don't have a whole
lot of moderators actually okay
dude yeah okay you're a moderator and um
don't abuse the power yeah
tbrigger said i think jenny is inspiring
me to shave the sides of my head you can
make you can make uh bees
just bees for now
okay
like you don't actually have to do
anything but no just just in case just
in case because like i said just i want
all my regulars to show up highlighted
too
because pretty much everybody's a
regular at this point now yeah even the
trolls are regular
although they keep changing they keep
changing their name but it's like
they're not fooling anybody yeah you
said i was a dark eye circle [ __ ]
faster looking [ __ ]
whatever had a big head and fat arms yes
he said he had fat arms no i said i had
father
so you know
which you know
okay they're not that they're not fat
well it's like i don't i'm not upset
because i'm like yeah i know they are i
do have fat arms and i do have a big fat
head
so it's like
okay good job you're very observant
so what's uh
we also watching um
okay she's oh i'm a moderator now yeah
we started watching uh cocaine cowboys
saw the first episode last night it was
really good although i fell asleep it
was like really it was really good but i
was like super super sleepy and i was
watching it and i was really entertained
but i was like
we can watch
watch the second half again if you want
i'm getting old i can't like you stay up
past like [ __ ] but i do wake up at
like six in the morning that's why yeah
actually this morning i woke up at
quarter to six
so that's why
so it starts getting around 9 30 10
o'clock i'm like i'm so sleepy
and i feel like a [ __ ] grandma but
you know
yeah if you guys haven't seen it you
should check it out and just they just
put that on netflix that wasn't there
before we looked for it remember uh if
they put it there it's probably been
there a week or two yeah okay i think
but it's good you know
it shows it's a florida man series man
uh
florida man yeah and it's like it talks
about starts off as uh
the miami area
in the uh early 80s
and into the 80s when the cocaine boom
hit and the narco wars happened down
there a lot of people forget about that
they're they're too young or they didn't
know
looking
south florida
was like columbia when i was a kid
growing up
and the average person didn't really
know what was happening
but this this uh
this series explains it and even the
guys who are doing it and it focuses on
one particular organized crime outfit
who were kind of like the uh the robin
hoods of the whole scene they they ten
they were kind of the least the the the
non-violent ones they weren't really
killing people the guy who was
in charge of it was making
a [ __ ] ton of money like several million
dollars a month
they were flying cocaine in from
colombia
and uh it was all friends that all grew
up together they went to high school
together
and they just
they tried to stay away from killing
people because it would just attract too
much attention
and he was getting arrested and throwing
it getting thrown into the local jails
here and then would just be released
mysteriously
you know like you're out because yeah i
don't even wonder
yeah we don't know how he got out he
just he was released you know [ __ ]
yeah it was pretty interesting
uh you know i've said some things on the
on the show
over the years about florida and i think
people think i'm joking and said no man
that is their territory down there
that
that's been
north cuba
um since before the united states even
existed and
you got people from new york moving down
there with money trying to throw their
weight around and it doesn't work that
way
in in florida
uh in south florida
it's cubans
and they run it
just that's just how it is thank you
zach yeah what's up with zach saying
here's irony for you our ac was out the
last three days and on the day it died i
was watching body heat of all things
yeah
could make a good review for y'all yeah
i actually have that on the list because
i do want to do that eventually
i have so many movies on the list i
swear but sometimes you do recommend
some and i do have them
um
yeah so so people are talking about the
uh
tom cruise dead or something people keep
making for bringing up tom tom cruise
yeah we saw that earlier like i said i
don't know if it's like one of those
celebrity hopes it might be a secret
jokes day maybe the scientologist killed
him oh yeah i've heard anything about
tom cruise today now they're going to
kill me just for saying that out loud
they're going to turn up at my doorstep
if he died then you know people are just
going to say his movie sucked anyway
i think top top gun part two never did
come out
there's i thought they were shooting
that well i didn't know
oh yeah okay okay just these pronouns
says no i was joking okay
no they shot it and um because the
pandemic hit it's been done for i think
for a year
well yeah a lot of movies have been well
because the thing about it is that a lot
of studios are kind of like yeah we
don't want to release our [ __ ] like
right to streaming because we won't make
our money back yeah you'll never get it
back but then yeah but then at least
like some movies were finally like okay
fine like you know we got to release it
to streaming otherwise we won't make
we'll make zero money you're gonna make
zero so like any money is better than
zero money yeah they're [ __ ] that
industry's [ __ ] toast
it's not coming back and they're saying
it's not coming back
you know just that's not going to come
back
because uh
the hollywood was dependent on amc
theaters and they
don't want to deal with the mc theaters
anymore they don't think theaters are
[ __ ] uh
a viable way to show a movie in terms of
cost there's a lot of overheads
and people don't really go anymore
although i think the reason why people
don't go is because the movies mostly
suck
well the thing about it too is that you
have to think that in the past you know
10 years people's home setups it's so
cheap now to get like a big huge tv and
a sound bar and all this other kind of
[ __ ]
that it's like dude next to you farting
and [ __ ] with his feet up on it going it
ain't the girl yeah yeah
yeah you can pause it and then go hold
on i gotta take a piss oh my god we were
watching the movies that made us the
other day and they had an episode on
jurassic park
and you said something that was very
grandpa-like yeah and that reminded me
of that dude all those years ago when i
saw the original jurassic park back in
[ __ ] 1993 was that why were we
watching we were watching we were
watching the movies that made us okay
the episode that was about jurassic park
and i remember you saying something
about it was just like some like weird
like clueless like is this the one where
this happens or that or does this happen
in this movie or something and then i
just kind of like it was a big pause and
i just went it ate the goat because
that's exactly what you sounded like
i think they were coming out of that um
coming out of that jeep and somebody
said something and i misunderstood what
you said and i misquoted
what he said
i couldn't understand what he said i
still remember that all these [ __ ]
years later
that i saw that movie in the theater me
and my friend jen saw that movie in the
theater and it was like awesome to see
in the theater but it's like ever it was
like the thing was full which i hate
and so there's people sitting next to us
there's people right behind us and all
this other stuff so the people behind us
were like these [ __ ] they had to be
at least 100 years old
and the dude i don't know he was deaf
and i don't think he maybe he was deaf
and he didn't really know what was going
on like on the screen because he just
like kept
you know he kept like turning to his
wife and being like who's this now
what's going on blah blah blah and he
was like really loud like he was like
talking like he was at home
and um
so
that and his wife was like she didn't
answer him or she would just be like shh
you know she'd be like that and you
could tell she was like super
embarrassed but he was just like
commenting on what was happening but he
was just like describing what was
happening on the screen
as if we couldn't see it also he's
describing it to himself so he can keep
track of it i guess so
i asked where did scientologists go
uh after they died
what you say there's something about 100
virgins scientology having with 100
virgins for everybody no no
scientologists are on what they call the
whole track all right
and the whole track is
successive
lifetimes
all right so they're they're kind of
reincar they believe in reincarnation
um that's how i remembered it so you
come back as an even more insufferable
scientologist douchebag sorry that's our
neighbor it's our neighbor he decides
it's time to mow his own lawn well i
can't blame people for waiting until
five or six o'clock in the evening to do
yard work in florida hottest though
because no it's not really like if you
do it [ __ ]
if you do it in the morning it's better
but
some people don't want to get up early
so you know there's that whole thing
well i understand is that that dude's
got all kinds of money he could just do
it we do like 80 90 a month you can have
[ __ ] a whole long crew come and get
the whole thing done in less than 10
minutes
yeah because they only come like they
come on fridays and like just kind of
they trim the hedges and everything they
always do like a really good job too i
did the math i think it's 100 a month
yep i did the math
[ __ ] all the fuel all the [ __ ]
uh maintenance costs for upkeep and lawn
mowers and [ __ ] all that [ __ ] in the
time it the time it takes me to do it
because i used to do it it did not check
out for a couple bucks more
go ahead and just hire some guys to do
it you don't have to go out there
well and especially the whole damn
blocks they're going and especially like
i said because yeah one they have a
bunch of other clients on the same
street so they can just like get
everybody done like in one day and two
we have a [ __ ] homeowners association
and if your grass isn't the right you
got some like [ __ ] btk [ __ ]
coming out of town or whatever you know
yeah like tell like finding you like hey
your hedges looking messy hey your grass
is too long hey you get like fined so
it's better to just like hire somebody
that knows what they're doing because if
you do it and it's not right then you
get fined so
yeah
sandra says oh no they reincarnate and
come back right we won't get rid of them
yeah
yeah they're um they're reincarnating um
they were
and every the better they do in this
life the better they reincarnate so in
other words if you're living a good life
it's because you earned it because you
did cool [ __ ] in the past
if you live in a sucky life you earned
that too because you [ __ ] up in the
past
and that you're not a scientologist
and then um
trying to think of another thing another
thing that they
they also of course believe in
alien possession that little alien
demonic souls haven't [ __ ]
embedded the females they're like stuck
yeah it's embedded into your soul
okay and uh that's the cause of all your
troubles and uh if you do enough
auditing which is like inquisition on a
lie detector
machine if you do enough auditing you
can exercise those demonic souls and
help you go along the whole track and
you're trying to move up the bridge
which is
it's levels you're trying to level up
and then i think when you get to like
ot9 you're almost like a perfect
scientologist and you won't get sick you
can that's adorable you have you can
adorable you can actually project you
can [ __ ] um
control space-time in other words travel
forward and backwards through time and
they have a weird way of describing how
that's done
um
another thing is is that if you join the
c organization you've so you signed the
contract for 10 000 years
no billion years
is it billion years yeah it's a billion
okay i thought it was ten thousand okay
billions okay
so every time you read the card in your
contract you have to go back to the sea
org
every time
so you're gonna be in the sea org for
[ __ ] a billion years
so even when you come back you still got
to do that yeah
l ron hubbard's [ __ ] mansion is and
he's got a mansion at every one of their
[ __ ] bases but his main mansion and
everything they keep them all ready and
spotless and ready to go and air
conditioned and everything because
they're waiting for l ron hubbard to
come back at any moment
uh they believe that you can return from
the [ __ ] the afterlife
yeah you guys just keep waiting for that
to happen kind of like a jedi
when obi-wan returned from the force you
know they believe in that kind of [ __ ]
i'm sure that's probably like what he
thought too yeah sandra's asking uh oh
oracle said they think they originally
started as clams if i'm remembering
properly yeah they do think uh elrond
hubbard did think that they evolved from
clams or
clam-like organisms
yeah
and uh oracle says and hey didn't
elrond believe in pilt-down man and not
realize that was a hoax that would not
shock me i'm not entirely sure but yeah
i think he did actually elrond would
like um
elrod hubbard okay hub hub
mother hubbard mother hubbard
chief hub
hubba bubba yeah
well you know
back in the day do more fishier lips yes
your lips do it when we were on the ship
you know i i would show people the stars
i could tell them
where all the aliens were this hair is
zeta reticuli
[Laughter]
and there they have the most ultimate
mind powers and control over their own
minds and bodies
they're all born ot9s i'm
didn't know that did you
meet me in my cabin
i'll tell you more about it
that's okay but uh yeah
that was [ __ ] elrod
hubbard what was i getting at hubbard
let's see it rubber no oh and tammy even
says somebody should show up and say
that they're elrond and move into one of
his mansions i told him he should do
that i should do it i could do it
this flesh i said
we were watching like i think we were
watching uh leah remedy's show and i was
like dude i was like oh my god we should
totally do this yeah do it they'd
believe it no they wouldn't because
david miscavige that's [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] get that little [ __ ] out of
here
well then you just whip his ass yeah
he's like he's a little tiny dude like
clash of the midgets
i'd [ __ ] whip his ass you would
that's what i'm saying so you just like
whip his ass and be like see [ __ ] i
told you and then like you would win
yeah
we could have like whole big mansion and
we could like we could that's not
hubbard we could have the whole [ __ ]
yeah yeah he could improve it yeah
the thing is is uh
hubbard was liked by the by the the cult
he was he was a
i mean some people get some
ex-scientologists might get really
pissed off because they suffered a lot
under
the yolk of the church
as far as cult leaders go [ __ ]
hubbard was a good one uh he didn't
mistreat
people i mean
you know that's a pretty low bar i got
to say he wasn't raping women or
anything he did that we know of
no they would they would that would have
leaked out
he was uh but he had he did dump wives
and and he dumped he would dump wives
and uh dump
children he's like i'm done with this
one you know what i mean
what do i care i don't know how to deal
with that [ __ ] i didn't bear that
human well he yeah they don't treat
children as children that everybody is
an adult no matter how old you are well
yeah because that's that whole like this
is an old soul you're a scientist blah
blah so that's justification for them to
treat children as though they're adults
just kind of leave them they can work
them like adults they can leave them on
their own like adults because they're
like yeah they're fine they'll figure it
out they're like i've been around a long
time
you take care of yourself yeah so you
know so they they kind of have like an
unempathetic kind of psychopathic kind
of [ __ ] lifestyle
um
but
but they liked hubbard hubbard sit
around entertain him a lot
he was just kind of a
bullshitter [ __ ] artist although i
think he did believe
in what he was talking about he did
believe his own [ __ ] i don't think
he did at first but maybe just the more
he talked about it like the more he
talked himself into it the more money he
had the more successful the church was
because there's kind of like like the
more money you make from it i guess the
more impetus there is for you to like
believe your own [ __ ] because the
more you believe you're in [ __ ] the
more you make other people believe it
and like the more successful you are so
it kind of like feeds on itself i don't
think he really thought
i mean because like there are multiple
sources
that say like early on he's like oh
where the money is you start a religion
so i think that was an actual like
cynical move on his part like him doing
that i think he knew
from the outset that he was like doing
something bullshitty but like the longer
it went on i think it was much easier
for him to like buy into his own
[ __ ] that's my theory yeah
but you're getting kind of ahead of the
gun
what he really wanted to do is replace
psychology
well yeah his own psychiatry psycho and
psychology yeah both of them he wanted
he wanted to replace them with his own
technology
but i think it was mostly
psychology is what he wanted because if
you could replace psychology that means
you could get scientology taught in
universities
and if you can
get your teachings
taught at a university
it it changes the whole dynamic you now
have you're now creating the ruling
class
so you can kind of in
inherit the earth over time
in other words you know what i mean the
leaders of the society are all
scientologists because that's what they
were taught at yale or harvard
and
made perfect sense that's because he was
looking at
he's looking at the frankfurt writers
the freight the the school the frankfurt
school and
you know who are like the fathers of
psychology
and that's just
he saw what they were doing he's like i
can do that i can do i can make a more
american version of that
and he tried it and failed though i mean
it was
social studies was too
too deeply rooted into the university
system already
but it could have easily been
scientology think of that
you could have it would have been
cleaned up over time same way psychology
has been
and social studies it would have they
would have tried to make that more of a
science but if the scientologists got
involved in the universities and bought
their way into that
muscled their way into the university
system [ __ ] imagine the damage they
could have done
well yeah
tammy says oh my god tell them pookie is
elrond
yeah
oh my god maybe we should i wouldn't
exploit pookie in such a fashion but
that would be [ __ ] funny though but
if you ask me
if you look at
psychology and social studies and stuff
it's a lot like fortune telling in a
certain way yeah people there are people
that have certain tendencies towards
certain things
uh but you know that's kind of like
astrology too
it's hard to prove what people are
thinking
it i don't it's not so much a science as
it is kind of like a philosophy
well the thing the thing about science
is that it's always on a spectrum it's
always done in percentages
you can't 100 predict what people are
going to do because people are
you know to to a small extent
unpredictable
so it's kind of like
i don't know i i don't like this whole
thing it's just kind of like oh well the
whole science should be thrown out
because she didn't predict this one
percent of people that did this crazy
[ __ ] it's like normally
that you know it's that's those are
outliers and it's like there's gonna be
that in any uh in any situation that's
not why i'm criticizing it though i'm
just saying that
a lot of
a lot a lot of
psychology and a lot of social studies
psychiatry does not did does not approve
of psychology
they scoffed at that for a long long
time well psychiatry is more science
yes well they're allowed to yeah they're
allowed to uh prescribe drugs and stuff
like that where a psychologist is not
allowed to prescribe drugs because
psychology psychology is like a
philosophy
or some would say almost like a faith
um there there's not a there's it's not
a hard science
same thing with social studies there's
bias in it too you know bias and opinion
it's just it's just something a
university could sell to somebody that's
it's a product all they're all products
but it's
it's not as not as hokey as scientology
but there's a lot of hokiness in it
um
i wouldn't i wouldn't pay for it
well i mean the thing about psychology
is that most people that are going to
like psychologists are just going there
to like just talk about their problems
it's not like so and that's mo that's
what most people that's all most people
need is they just want somebody to
listen to them and like you know listen
to their problems i don't really have
like i said you know psychiatry as far
as i know this is how it was when i was
in school and a little bit later because
you know i took a lot of psychology
classes and they're like if you're a
psychologist you know that's you still
have to be licensed and everything but
they can't actually prescribe drugs
because they don't
do the same in-depth [ __ ] on like brain
chemistry and all the stuff that
psychiatry does because psychiatry is
more like a medical field and when that
stuff started to make it into the
educational system it was controversial
back then people you can still go back
and critique it because is this a
science should this be taught in school
are you going to teach chiropractic
you know what about being a chiropractor
you're going to put that in university
what about
horoscopes you know in astrology you're
going to put that in there you know i
mean where do you draw the line
that's really what the question is
it's just
a lot of people were saying that that is
not a science that that is
a philosophy well they call it a soft
science it's a software
or a faith you know
and then you just end up kind of duping
people in to go taking it and it's very
difficult to make money with that
me ex with the exception of maybe like
advertising
because you can weaponize it and make
propaganda with it
uh but but is that psychology or is this
now propaganda you know or is this my
control there's a lot of weird [ __ ]
that's been done over the years the cia
did weird things in mental institutions
up in canada that we talked about
there's a lot of weird things that i
don't know if it's actually a science
but it kind of works you know erasing
somebody's mind using drugs and sensory
deprivation and brainwashing and you can
do weird [ __ ]
but should you be teaching that
well i don't think anyone's teaching
that no
but you know i'm just saying
if if it's a reality why shouldn't you
teach it should you even should you let
people know that that exists or that
that's possible or is it too dangerous
to let the pub public know
that you can basically
erase a human being's mind
over time and put a new one in there in
a way um
to an extent i think having more
information about things even if it's
unpleasant i think is better
um because
yes you're gonna get the small
percentage of people that are going to
like use that for evil but most people i
kind of think that it's better to know
that that exists that that exists and
that's it's better to be like prepared
for that kind of [ __ ] yeah you know what
i'm saying like if somebody tries to do
that on you like for example um i think
it's better to like recognize it yeah so
because that's the thing i think like
teaching people something and advocating
that thing are two different things
that's two completely different things
you know what i mean it's like so just
because you teach somebody about a
certain thing that doesn't mean oh i
endorse this you know what i'm saying
you're just like teaching hey this is
something that happened or this is
something that you might encounter
then you know this is something that
exists so we're telling you about it and
i don't have a problem with that at all
yeah
but then again you can look at
you can look at certain aspects of
psychology
and you teach people this
parts of this subject and you teach it
as if it's true when it may not be true
but then they go out in the real world
and get jobs in corporations and apply
what they learned to the general
population
uh and the whole thing's a falsehood
it's like a it's it's like it's like
witch doctory you know and and it fails
it's just there's certain things that
just
they shouldn't be taught in a university
because i just don't think they have a
place in the market or in an actual life
you know or they're just a detriment
imagine if science scientology was in
there
you'd want to get that out wouldn't you
well here's the thing though i i kind of
feel like
honestly i don't you know i don't think
this would be like general education or
anything but if you were doing like for
example
uh if you were doing like your studies
like and i'm talking like you know
master's level or whatever if you're
doing that in
like world religions for example or if
you're even doing sociology or something
like that i have no problem at all with
them teaching you about scientology
because they're not advocating it right
they're just teaching you this is what
they do
and maybe but like i said the more
people know about scientology the more
people know about that is yeah of course
but that's not what i'm saying what if
scientology was in the university system
being taught
as a truth in other words they were in
there and they're teaching l ron
hubbard's principles
as if it was a real education imagine
that that's what scientology does
the church of scientology was built
because it couldn't get into the
university systems the the the orgs were
a substitute for a university yeah
because everyone was like yeah that's
[ __ ] they wanted it in the
universities though because they believe
it to be well you know the creationists
try to get their [ __ ] taught in like
elementary school science class too and
they did not succeed right but because
you don't have any [ __ ] to back that up
but psychology's in there and stuff from
the frankfurt schools in there and
that's every bit as [ __ ] insane as
scientology every bit
wait you believe that you believe that
[ __ ] little
children should be given to pedophiles
i mean who said that
foucault fuco taught that that got into
the german system right but it's like
address based on based on on on on
foucault's work
um the german government was giving
placing
um
orphans
uh
they were giving them to pedophiles
knowingly
but that's obviously crazy that's
obviously great the german government
didn't think it was crazy yeah but how
long ago was that a few years ago
how long ago was that
that would never fly yeah sandra when
did that when did that happen it ended a
few years ago but i think it started in
the 90s or the 80s
yeah
and it had went on for a long time the
german public didn't know
but there was some stuff between
foucault and some other guys and they
were part of that whole frankfurt school
they were they were actually tenured
professors in universities doing
psychology and social studies they were
saying that that should have been the
one of the new
alternate family models is that you can
take all these um
uh uh uh what do you call them
orphans and
and and pair them up with uh a pedophile
pedophiliac adults
so i think and and they even wrote about
it they had some kind of immunity
as professors that they couldn't go to
prison for what they were doing but they
were it was co and a couple of other
ones i can dig them up for you
one of them was a german dude
and he raised like three or four
sons that were also his boyfriends from
like early ages
sandra probably knows about it
but that got into the university systems
like okay i don't know enough about that
but it just kind of seems like
no they got they got they got the german
social services to accept that go oh
okay i guess that is healthy there's no
problem with that and they did that
well like i said it's like they do
stupid [ __ ] all the time that doesn't
mean that
you know nowadays sandra says she's
never heard of it she'll look it up yeah
it did yeah it went it went down
i think it was mostly happening in the
90s
i never heard about that yeah
the german social services had put like
thousands of them in those homes
but they got old enough to where they
could they could come forward and
[ __ ] complain about it
i mean the thing is that wouldn't fly
nowadays now
it was now like a long time ago
that [ __ ] would have like the 90s was a
long time ago
um but i'm just saying i don't know like
like i said i don't know i can't argue
with it because i don't know like i've
never heard of that yeah uh sanders
never heard of it so we've never heard
of that so i can't some of you guys some
of you guys who are live you can dig
that up it was going on and then they
tried to hush it up but it did happen
you know but like [ __ ] up should
happen
like i said that doesn't mean just
because one little thing like some
weirdo gets their [ __ ] in somewhere and
it's just kind of like oh well that just
means we have to like take the whole
[ __ ] system oh we can't teach you
anything about that that wasn't the
american system that was yeah we taught
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] too don't overreact
it's okay we talked we taught some
[ __ ] [ __ ] talking about i was just
talking about
i'm just talking about
what is possible
with systems just because something is
in the government system doesn't mean
that it's right well nobody said that
because that something's in a university
system doesn't mean nobody said that
either you go back 200 years to 300
years [ __ ] what they would teach in
these [ __ ] little alchemy schools and
[ __ ] like it was all wrong
you know everything's always changing
well like i said the reason that it
changes is that we build on knowledge of
the past
and that's good that we do that because
like you know yeah some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happened in the past people had stupid
beliefs in the past people have stupid
beliefs now you have them right now but
you know the the more we go on we're
more like oh man that was stupid let's
not do that anymore like we're just like
in a constant process of like learning
[ __ ] yeah you know what i'm saying it's
like yes we backslide sometimes yes
there's like you know
two-step you know it's two steps forward
one step back pretty much but
on the whole
most of the [ __ ] that flew a hundred
years ago would never fly now and
rightfully so yeah that wasn't a hundred
years ago that was so well i'm not i'm
just saying in general i'm just saying
in general yeah
you know whatever that was i never heard
of it but okay
whatever that was that wouldn't fly
nowadays there's another thing that
happened
that they [ __ ] brushed underneath the
carpet
and i remembered seeing uh i
remember seeing it was a they had a
hearing a congressional hearing a bunch
of women who came from uh
i think we might have talked about it on
one of our shows they came from the
orphanage system and the um
the what do you call it the uh
what do you
foster home systems
they got sent
to um
i think it was somewhere in canada
yeah i remember psychologists
and they were doing that mind wiping on
those girls well it was one particular
psychologist and yeah and they were
doing weird things like uh
molesting them keeping them in cages as
little kids and raising them kind of
like animals and forcing them to become
multiple personalities to have most
multiple persons well they were yeah
well there was this one guy and he was
like a whack job and he wanted to see
yeah if but he was working for the cia
but yeah well i don't yeah i don't know
if that was like something to do with
them or just doing on his own
the idea was was to make a sex operative
who was a multiple personality
uh so
some of the personalities were were like
um cover story personalities another one
was was an agent or like sex agents like
a secret agent and another was an
assassin
so you could take a little girl
and
have her hang around some area and have
her hook up with some dude who
some dude who was a target and he'd have
sex she could have sex with him and then
get a bunch of dirt on him and they
could run him on remote control with the
dirt that she had on him and um they
could flip her from one
personality to the next using certain
code words
and if they wanted to do dead they could
flip her over to a [ __ ] to a an
alternate personality that was an
assassin and she'd shoot him
it's pretty [ __ ] wild
and they had like 10 of them women
although from
the 60s though well from what i can
determine about that a lot of it like
they did try to kind of do that stuff
primarily in the 50s and 60s um but it
didn't work out uh because like i said
people are too unpredictable they don't
see you can't it didn't have to work
what was weird is that they were doing
this to orphans and girls that were in
foster homes well i mean back in the day
it was they didn't give up okay so let
me let me just say because uh the next
book review i'm gonna be doing let me
make another drink is yeah
is uh the jack ketchum book the the girl
next door which uh like i said
if you're real like sensitive to [ __ ]
like
realistic [ __ ] please do not read this
book because i've read it like three
times now and every time it just like
makes me like
so angry but honestly reading it and
then reading about the real case that
it's based on
and something that really struck me
is that
uh the actual case which
if you want to know what the actual case
was go to wikipedia i mean if you have a
strong stomach go to wikipedia
and um look up the murder of sylvia
lykins
it happened in the midwest i think it
was in indiana in the 60s at some point
now the book is like a fictionalized
version of it it happened in the 50s but
something that he was kind of like
dancing around in the book that really
struck me was that particularly in the
50s and 60s when you were a kid
you didn't have any power no one really
believed you about stuff and it just
seemed kind of like casual child abuse
casual spousal abuse was very much
accepted and that was kind of like he
doesn't really like belabor that point
in the book but it does kind of like
bring that whole thing home especially
when you read about the actual case that
it was based on
um all of these like an adult
participated and it was a woman
and a bunch of her kids participated a
bunch of the neighbor kids participated
and even though some people like the
neighbors and [ __ ] like kind of knew
that something wasn't right over there
they just thought oh well you know that
happens like kids and wives and whatever
need to be slapped around so it's like
nobody really reported it
yeah because that was just like part of
the culture
so
you know that was just like something
that i was like thinking of earlier not
sure exactly what you talk about yeah
where was this
it happened in indiana in the 60s
a woman and her kids and a bunch of the
neighborhood kids
uh essentially tortured
uh a girl i remember that one yeah you
were telling me about that yeah sylvia
likens because like i said the the book
review i'm doing this this book right
here
uh
is based on that case this is a
fictionalization fictionalization
um but it's based on it they made a
couple movies based on it as well just
because
super [ __ ] up because it's one of
those kind of like oh you know back in
the good old days 50s and 60s nobody
locked their doors made picking fences
blah blah blah it was all that kind of
[ __ ] and then this kind of [ __ ] was
going on behind closed doors and no one
did anything
because it was just kind of like hey
kids get slapped around well there were
some trashy ass [ __ ] places and nooks
and crannies
everywhere even in the united states but
in other
you
countries
too
i mean
there was [ __ ] going on out out in the
middle of nowhere in certain places and
you know what i mean dumbbell tenements
and big cities you'd never know what was
going on there
that went back to the 1800s 1700s
probably
[ __ ] look at the weird [ __ ] that's
happening in the 1400s the 1300s with
like you know see that's not his
bathroom that's what i mean it's kind of
like i do kind of feel like that's why
i'm always really skeptical of people
that are always kind of like oh we're
going back some golden age what if i'm
like when the [ __ ] was this magical time
never that was never
even like and the thing about it is that
like the more i looked into you know all
these cases like when i was writing
faceless villain particularly the first
volume which was like the first 50 years
of the 20th century
man some really [ __ ] up [ __ ] happened
back then really [ __ ] up [ __ ] and the
thing about it is that
they didn't have and i feel like they
didn't have the same sensibility about
it as people would nowadays
i kind of feel like i mean jack the
ripper case being the exception but i
kind of felt like in the late victorian
era early 20th century like you know
somebody kills a bunch of prostitutes or
bums or something like that no one
really gives a crap unless it's like
super super egregious you know what i
mean well i think they cared i think
they just i think they were just kind of
realized that there was no way to catch
them so they were just kind of oh well
it's going to happen you know how it is
can't catch them they didn't have the
technology to catch them
i think they were just kind of resigned
to it
like oh yeah they do it you know
yeah well you live like that that's what
happens it happens we can't do anything
about it living on streets this is what
happened we can't catch it well they
couldn't catch that dude
well yeah they probably human
human nature seems to be a constant for
the most part
you go back and just read roman history
and what was going on in ancient rome
it's the same people pretty much
there were some differences in the
culture like religion was very very big
and there's lots of different religions
and i think there's a reasons why
probably and that was what two 2000
years ago
but if you go through those history
books
the things that individual people do
a lot of times you're like yeah okay you
know you know yeah that's something a
person would do but a lot of it was bad
too you know it's just the mixtures it's
what seems to be kind of out of the
ordinary at least in western
in western history the history of
western civilization
was the middle ages certain aspects of
the dark ages were pretty [ __ ] bad
and it just got to be because people
were just so dumb
you know well they're just dumb and i i
feel like they just felt like they had
license to just do whatever or like
everyone else was doing that too so
they're just kind of like well i guess
we just all suck and they just all like
did the same kind of [ __ ] because i feel
like
well like i said and kind of thinking
about uh cassandra said i think she
wasn't even that long in prison was she
like the woman yeah kirch gertrude uh
baniszewski banished something like that
um she was in prison for a while and she
was a model prisoner but they did
actually eventually let her out she's
dead now she died of lung cancer at a
fairly young age i think she was 61
but
you know when they were going to let her
out on parole like everybody of course
freaked out because the thing about it
though and he kind of goes into this in
the book which like i said is a
fictionalization and i'll probably get
more into this on the book review
because you know i'm going to record the
book review tomorrow probably or friday
and it's like i wanted to like talk
about this
but
i kind of feel like the thing about it
was that all these kids it was her kids
it was girls and boys
and a bunch of the neighbor kids and
they were basically they kept this girl
who was staying with them she was like a
friend of the
she was like friends with their parents
and the parents were like off working
and so she was keeping her and her
sister
in the house with them like watching
them for a few months until their
parents until their parents came back
and they just somehow got it in their
head that they were just gonna like
basically imprison this girl in the
basement
and torture her
for fun
um and a lot of the people got involved
and i think a lot of the kids got
involved because
and like i said he kind of goes into
this in the story was because an adult
said it was okay
weird like because the she was an adult
and they had all kind of hung out at
that house they all it was one of those
neighborhoods where everybody knew each
other all the kids played together blah
blah blah so it's like if one adult says
everything's all right
then
okay then i guess what we're doing is
okay like it gave them a pass and it's
like a really horrifying
like just the whole dynamic of it is
like really really horrifying that's why
this book i think is so [ __ ] [ __ ]
up everywhere i've read it like i said
three times and it like freaks me out
every single year yeah that's not a
normal situation though you had a
psychopathic adult with a bunch of
children
and some kind of weird yeah well
thankfully it's not a normal well i kind
of feel like and he goes into this more
in the fictionalized version i don't
know
about what the real woman felt
but i do kind of felt like she got a
little bit of a sexual charge
um out of torturing this pretty young
girl
because
she was older or she'd been [ __ ] over
by life she
you know she didn't feel like she had a
future so i kind of feel like she took
great delight
and almost some kind of like weird
sexual enjoyment it's called sadism yeah
in
in torturing this pretty young girl
who had a future ahead of her except not
anymore because she died
from the torture so you know
how did she not know that that was going
to kill that girl
and at some point it made her think that
that girl wasn't going to tell
the weird thing about it was that
it was kind of like this strange like
escalation situation like i said
now
they were kind of like i said she was
friends with their with their parents
because it wasn't just her it was her
and her sister
and her sister had had polio so she was
part of she had like a leg brace so she
couldn't like move around that good
um but the older sister was the one that
they mostly tortured they kind of
tortured the younger one too
but
i kind of feel like it got to a point
because the first two weeks they were
there apparently everything was totally
fine like these two girls are staying
here with us for a little while you know
their parents are going to be away for i
think it was from like august to
november or something like that they
were like they they were carnival
workers they travel with a fair
so she was watching them
and then for whatever reason
after two weeks had passed uh this woman
decided that the older girl sylvia was a
[ __ ]
i don't know why she wasn't
um and she decided she was gonna punish
her what about the young girl did they
did they do anything with a young girl
uh some stuff she didn't well she didn't
get it as bad as the older one
um she was however forced to
also torture her sister
like or she would get her the [ __ ]
kicked out of her as well even though
like i said she was crippled but she
lived
she did
and she testified against the
[ __ ] yeah i mean she came out
and was like they did this and they
explained that that the daughter had
died to the parents
did they call the cops when she died
they didn't i think what happened was i
can't remember like all the details but
i think it ended up that
she ended up dying from all the torture
she was tortured malnourished
they didn't give her enough water
um all this other kind of stuff they had
carved
they carved something into her stomach
um
i'm a prostitute
[ __ ] me or something like that
um in her under her stomach like with a
with a needle
you know they've done all kind of
horrible things to her
uh burn you know burned her with
cigarettes like just [ __ ] you know
just beat the crap out of her and they
kept her down in the basement and didn't
feed her and didn't give her water and
[ __ ] like that so she had like all kind
of like multiple organ failures and like
all these bug it's like a horrible
horrible like like i said if you want to
like
uh weep for humanity go read the [ __ ]
wikipedia because it's like it's yeah i
read it earlier today because like i
said i finished reading the novel and i
wanted to like remind myself of like
what the real [ __ ] was and i was just
kind of like
i mean the book is worse
the you know the i don't know how she
does that to herself i could never read
that [ __ ]
i can't i
i don't look down into that [ __ ]
abyss i have to because
i don't know what it is it bothers me
but i feel like i have to because it's
like these are the people that are
sharing my planet
uh so i need to know what they're up to
yeah you know what i mean uh just well
it's good to know those people exist but
i don't consider them to be sharing a
planet with me
well they are though no they're not
those aren't humans those are monsters
humans are monsters i would agree that i
i don't i don't agree i think there's
yeah i think there's something missing
that makes them like sub-human yes
uh particularly this [ __ ] woman
who
deserved a lot worse than she got oh
yeah um i'd have broken her neck
worse
i mean i feel like i don't want to be as
bad as her
but
the [ __ ] that and she never
um
she never like really
apologized she never even came out and
said like she
took responsibility
i mean no she even she would come out
and said yeah she was sorry that she
died but then she kind of like threw her
kids under the bus and her kids did the
[ __ ] too and the kids were older they
were teenagers so they knew better but
the fact that
she never really took full
responsibility and was like hey what i
did was [ __ ] up she never even said
that
she was always kind of like oh well i
didn't really know what was going on i
was like i had depression and i was like
on all these drugs and i didn't know all
this stuff was going on in my house
and i'm like yeah nobody believed that
um so the fact that she didn't even take
responsibility for it
it's like look i'm sure she was mentally
ill okay but
that excuse only goes so far when you're
torturing
a 15 year old girl to death you know
what i'm saying in your [ __ ] house
and getting your kids and the
neighborhood kids down on the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i mean what
that is like
some next level [ __ ] up [ __ ] that is
next level and the thing about it it's
like serial killers that bothers me all
that stuff bothers me well that's
interesting this
this [ __ ] bothers me more because she
got seemingly normal people to go in on
it they weren't normal well they were
kids yeah but the fact that she gave
like license she's an adult yeah we're
supposed to like listen to adults
they're the authority so the fact that
she was doing it almost gave them
license like oh it's okay
so we can all just come over and hey
we'll just like beat this girl up and
like you know burn her with cigarettes
and it's funny and actually one of her
sons i think when he was testifying at
the trial he was like smirking and stuff
and she was dead yeah but the girl was
dead for some reason they hated her
you know and it's like so he didn't
learn anything no they thought she
deserved it he didn't learn anything
they just thought they thought she
deserved it
that's why i was saying that you know
she's saying that it's kind of like you
know they got normal people to do this i
guarantee you man if i got in there and
[ __ ] watched them and see find out
what they were doing back they wouldn't
have been normal
they probably uh
that area was probably who knows
they sound like there are some super
[ __ ] self righteous [ __ ]
you know what i mean might have been to
kill somebody in that way you have to
feel that you're doing the right thing
so what was it there what was it now
even like if you think you're doing the
right thing you think you're doing it
for like vengeance or something that's
that that person to avenge an evil that
that person did so for some reason
they believed that this well that was
one of the justifications that they gave
was that she had done something evil was
that she was a [ __ ] that she was
promiscuous she wasn't because the
autopsy showed that she was still a
virgin so she obviously wasn't she was
just like fifteen or six so
what's up with these people right to
where they're [ __ ] ultra [ __ ]
concerned over whether or not something
shakes a [ __ ] or not
so i i guarantee they're seeing exactly
that there there's something right there
on there is the crux of the matter and
it sounds like some kind of [ __ ]
sanctimonious [ __ ] uh uh yeah that's
exactly what it is bloodbath the [ __ ]
virtue signaling that they're good and
this chick's bad well they kind of well
yeah like some of that came out of the
trial like i said in the fictionalized
account the jack ketchum book he kind of
goes a little bit more into that because
like some of the kid or like the one kid
that is kind of like the protagonist of
the book he tries to like tell somebody
else and the other people are like
catholics and they're kind of like well
she must have done something you deserve
being beaten up like that
so yeah so it's kind of like and like i
said back in the 50s and 60s that's what
i was talking about before um if you
kind of beat on your kid or you beat on
your wife or whatever it must have been
because they kind of deserved it in some
way like i feel like that was a lot more
acceptable i was gonna say how much you
bet they all went to the same church
yeah they might have yeah i kind of feel
like this is yeah this is that kind of
situation so like i'm saying if people
are like it's an equivalent of like a
stoning like you'd see [ __ ] pakistan
or some [ __ ] yeah yeah which like i said
if you guys i've been watching more of
the handmaid's tale because remember i
told you
that i have to do i'm going to do like a
show like a panel discussion show about
it um they were actually going to record
it a couple weeks ago but everyone was
behind so i was like please you know
everybody needed more time because i was
like dude i'm only on like the i only i
was only in the middle of season one at
that point so they pushed it back like
the recording to the the end of august
so i've been like trying to like watch
it all so i'm probably like the middle
or toward the end of season two at this
point
and it's kind of like even though like
there's some aspects of that show which
are you know kind of out there and it's
just like oh that probably couldn't
happen but then like when i think about
it i'm like but yeah but
things like this have happened in this
country and in other countries you know
either in in the recent past or
you know fairly recently so it's not
that far out of it's not that crazy so i
do kind of feel like
as much as
i mean i don't know like i feel like if
you read jack ketchum's book or you saw
the movies which were based on it
because the first movie was called the
girl next door and there was also one
called an american crime which was a lot
more
faithful to the actual case and if you
read about the actual case it's like
it's un it's like unbelievable but in a
way it's not because it's like this kind
of [ __ ] i don't know it goes on like all
the time like and especially if you have
these kind of this kind of like veneer
of respectability which i kind of feel
like he kind of like gets into some in
like the book
where it's just like i said it's this
kind of like middle class 50s
picket fence sort of neighborhood but
then all these kids are just hey let's
come over and torture the girl in the
[ __ ] basement and you can totally see
how it would happen you can totally see
how it could happen because it's kind of
like
it's
you know it's just this escalation
the fact that these kids are coming over
to this house
the woman
uh in the fictional book she's called
ruth in real life she was named gertrude
but these kids come over you know she
just lets lets them get to get away with
little things oh you can stay at night
oh you can have a beer out of the fridge
oh you can have a smoke it's fine i'm
not going to tell your parents blah blah
so the fact that she lets them get away
with these little things like that
like when
these two girls come and it's just it's
very very slow like the escalation and
the fact that there's an adult there
who's always been like a friend to them
and is now saying oh this is okay and
now this is okay and now this is okay
um
that's kind of how it all
took place and i feel like the real one
kind of happened like that too
so
it's like it's alarming because you can
see how it could happen but thankfully
this is like a very very and even in
indiana still they like talk about this
[ __ ] case it's like being one of the
worst things that happened there ever
that orange juice and coconut taste is
kind of good in it it's different
yeah i like the orange brush i probably
like the orange juice and coconut like
best of uh everything
yeah somebody's talking about mad men
man i need to get back on that i watched
like the first
how many seasons of bad ben have there
been i think i watched like the first
three or four seasons and i loved them
and then
i either
didn't have cable anymore or no somebody
was taping them all for me like back in
the old days
um
somebody was taping them all for me like
burning them to dvd and then i was
watching them and then i didn't work
there anymore like somebody used to work
with
and then so i kind of like lost track of
it but one of these days
again just like [ __ ] twin p oh he's
throwing the hat down okay
dgm x that i finished mad men years ago
i have so much [ __ ] stuff i got to
catch up on god damn it
god damn it
then no need for me to says i ditch mad
men around season five i think i really
i love that show so much and it's just
kind of like i wanted to like watch the
whole thing
in the just because for now says what's
the wiki page oh my god what's the wiki
page wikipedia for what
murder of sylvia likens
like i said
it's not a fun read so
just telling you i don't know why you
guys get up all into that [ __ ] man i'm
not well like i said
you share a planet with these people
you share a plan with all kinds of
[ __ ] i don't want to hear about
them
well i want to know about these kind of
[ __ ]
because it's just nasty
because well because you don't know like
that kind of thing this is why i'm
fascinated i think by
you know like the documentary series we
watched the other day like the ted bundy
one like that was like from her
girlfriend's perspective and like from
all the victims perspective perspective
because you have to think that it's like
she just met some dude and like started
dating him and like hey he was like
really nice to her kid and he was super
nice and everything and she didn't know
any different
and then all of a sudden oh guess what
turns out he's a [ __ ] serial killer
so it's like you have to know i don't
know it's like
that's just so rare though i know but
it's like you but but it fascinates me
that you
that you could just like be with this
dude
and then like not know
and i don't think she knew she didn't
know like until later and then she
started getting a little suspicious like
with the car and everything and she was
like maybe this mother then she reported
him because like good for her what's up
if you read the details of what he was
doing
decapitating these women and having sex
with the heads and keeping the head
for a while until it got which it wasn't
much more
yeah and he yeah he was [ __ ] i just
can't imagine
yeah
he was brutal
i mean because i kind of feel like
the thing about it is that and i think
that's why i'm kind of fascinated with
btk as well because it's like
not only i'm not only interested in
their psychology like what the [ __ ] is
the matter with them but i'm also
interested in particularly ones like ted
bundy and btk and stuff like that that
had a semblance of a normal life outside
of their cereal killing uh you know
proclivities
and
i kind of try to put myself in the shoes
of their wife or their girlfriend or
whatever and i'm just like how the [ __ ]
would you feel
if you found out i mean that could like
go for any serial killer because like
what if you were like their sister or
their mom or something like that and
it's just kind of like how the [ __ ]
would that make you feel
finding that out about somebody that you
thought you knew you know what i mean
that like that wigs me out so it's like
that's that's why i'm kind of like
fascinated by that kind of [ __ ] not
because i get off on it i don't like
anything like that i'm just like trying
to put myself
i try to put myself in the in the shoes
of the victims and in the
in the shoes of like their family
members
and how that must feel to like find that
out about somebody like that like what
how would i feel if i found out my
brother was a serial killer how would i
find you know what like what would that
feel like
like that must be like the worst [ __ ]
thing ever
i don't know i'm a guy i don't even
think about that
maybe you should i don't worry about
what would it feel like you know i don't
maybe guys should feel maybe you guys
should worry more about that kind of
thing and they wouldn't be such [ __ ]
what would that feel like that's not i
wouldn't even think about that
well that's why well that's because
that's because dudes are uh kind of
sociopaths
and they're not really like empathetic
they're not really that empathetic how
would that make you feel i don't know if
i can it had it didn't happen to me so
you know
because you can't spend your whole life
wondering you know what would that feel
like or what would this be i'm not
spending my whole life doing that i'm
just saying that when i read about it
you know for whatever reason because i'm
interested in or we're doing a show
whatever you meant my stepdad
right yeah okay if you came to me and
says that it was a serial killer i would
just go of course he was well i would
probably believe you all though
but i had met yourself i had met your
stepfather of course he was well there
are some people that i've met thank you
zach which serial killer criminal do you
have the most sympathy for ooh that's a
hard one
none of them really
um
i don't know if you have if you like put
a gun in my head that maybe jeffrey
dahmer but
i don't know like that my sympathy only
goes like so for the i was like maybe
like 0.02 percent sympathy for that
because like i said you're still an
adult like i said i you know
yes it's [ __ ] up that they have like
[ __ ] up childhoods a lot of them do
but once you're an adult yeah
you have choices
okay
um
you know to an extent
so you choose to do that [ __ ] up [ __ ]
um unless you are really really mentally
ill
i i don't have a lot of i don't have a
lot of because
you know
if you start doing that
you're going to end up going well
maybe we should
have maybe we should tolerate them
because
serial killing is just their sexual
orientation see no one's gonna do that
though but that's what it is
i know but
so they're gonna say
they're gonna put that on the stripe and
one of the rainbow flags they're gonna
put like [ __ ] off no there's lots
no they're not that's what they would
try to do well not them but a serial
killer would try to do that they go no
i'm like yeah
but that's what they're gonna say
they're going to say you know a serial
killer is going to say what's my sexual
orientation yeah and he wouldn't be
lying
yeah but see other people's sexual
orientation isn't taking other people's
lives or taking other people's uh bodily
autonomy it all depends on how slowly
you can get somebody to accept something
it's like it's it's like bdsm but you
take it one step further
like the dude who [ __ ] hooked up with
the other german guy who agreed to
cannibalize him okay see now in that
case i'm conflicted about it like that
see he wants to be
that's the thing and this is
well it's all no i didn't say it was all
right but no i'm just saying that you
know consent is like the biggest is a
person
are they completely cognizant
are they completely mentally okay like
can they you know as long as they're not
a kid or they're not [ __ ] drunk or
[ __ ] up or something like that can
they consent to this do they know like
what the [ __ ]
consequences of this are
um i'm not saying they shouldn't put
that dude in jail because that's still
murder
but
i mean somebody is that is that [ __ ]
up that is willing to be like hey yeah
like eat my dick i'll eat it too
um that person clearly has issues i
don't i don't think that i don't think
it's okay that he ate that dude yeah i
don't think that's okay
rapists aren't considered a sexual
[ __ ] um orientation neither of pedos
i would say no you're wrong you're very
wrong they consider it to be a sexual
orientation well no one else does it is
a deviant sexual orientation but if you
look at the history
most of what we're doing even if you're
straight would be considered deviant
sexuality for 200 years ago or 100 years
ago oh you go anal we that's a hanging
offense oh wait a minute oral sex
hanging offense but like i said a lot of
[ __ ] [ __ ] like the thing about it
everything was deviant the thing about
it though is that the one thing like i
said is is it consensual or not right
like i said that's a that is that is a
modern bourgeoisie idea
once once you [ __ ] get that once
everything is stripped away except the
consent thing you can say well the
difference between consent and and
consenting and not consenting is very
gray you see
she didn't fight hard enough
so therefore it's like i've heard that
one oh yeah they'll do that in other
countries i know they'll do that another
i've heard so i've heard it in this
country like not for a couple decades
but hard enough so therefore she was
scared and stopped resisting so she did
so no man [ __ ] you can you can you
can convince anybody of anything you can
convince a society of anything all you
gotta do is look at some of these other
civilizations oh she was wearing that
skirt oh of course she wanted to get
raped
there are countries that are like that
well it it was like that here until
recently yeah i don't know and and
honestly even go back i'm not sure about
now but it's like if you were raped and
you actually like went to trial they
will absolutely ask you what you were
wearing yeah
even though that's really not a relevant
question and nothing is a constant
nothing lasts forever oh [ __ ] it it
could go back to that
i mean you know you you got to the point
to where now where you might have people
like they're fighting over [ __ ] you
got people
you got people saying they want to ban
anime because the boobs are too big on
the girls and girls aren't built like
that and then girls will [ __ ] post in
the comment of course they're built like
that you show the [ __ ] girls boobs so
it's going back to modesty oh they can't
the male gays we gotta get rid of the
male gays cover these women up
so now you got and these are maybe they
should just cut dudes dicks off that
would solve them no these are social
activists these are women saying that
cover these girls up that's girls saying
that
i'm not saying that no i i don't you're
not up you're not up for what's going on
on twitter and everything i'm not adding
on what's going on you're not yeah
that's what's going on there he's he's
up on what's going on tiny little fringe
no [ __ ] and he thinks that i'm not up on
it it's about comic books so a bunch of
dorks
are up on some [ __ ] okay
maybe you guys in the comment in the
comment section because she doesn't
really believe what i say she thinks i'm
constantly full of [ __ ] for some reason
you guys can [ __ ] explain to her
what's going on between anime and
american comics
american comics david june thank you tom
buy a fake mustache yeah you can give
wisdom as btk yeah that's right yeah
yeah i mean you know yeah uh yeah victor
said that's more than likely be
conservative bible thumpers yeah i kind
of feel like that too what's she talking
about um no no no it was feminist
feminists that were attacking
and i'm a feminist and i'll give a [ __ ]
about amen they were attacking anime
because it was hyper sexualizing women
and and objectifying women
this is a very very small
it doesn't matter
of feminism nobody likes it it doesn't
matter if it's a small french we're just
talking about the argument
you can argue but if you're arguing
between some fringe group and some other
fringe group no one cares about that you
can argue anything
it's just like it's like one it's like
five people on twitter arguing against
another five people on twitter that is
not relevant it's not relevant but it
can grow
but it won't because it's ridiculous
during the cultural revolution in maoist
china
all
femininity was considered to be
bourgeoisie
and as a sign of capitalism and a sign
of sexism against women and
objectification of women so all women
wore those little green uniforms they
didn't wear you they didn't wear makeup
and they didn't wear you know what i
mean they cut their hair clothes and
everything and the idea was to make a
woman look like a man
in mount in the in the maoist cultural
revolution
because it was two middle class two
bourgeoisie
two denigrating other women
too much you know women being valued
upon their beauty and all that kind of
[ __ ] so they had to get rid of all that
you can go in any direction and
eventually come back around where you
began you could argue circular the
argument can be circular i was in sales
jenny
you can blow through anything you keep
pushing it in a direction it'll come
it's like a circle it'll come right back
around
you can do anything with anybody
it just takes time and pressure
and especially pure peer pressure
and societal pressure
and that's why you have
islam would argue that islam would argue
women have to be covered up because
it's uh it's against women's rights
having them walk around naked and
with their boobs out that's that's but
the argument is really that men can't
control themselves because they are
savages
that's what it really well yeah it's a
it's a feminist argument exactly
basically
all right so it's sexist against women
and men there you go
that's why in philosophy but everybody
knows that though no no never doesn't
know that
what what the truth is always [ __ ]
centrism
and reason and rationality and not
overreacting and not being emotional
don't over emotionalize everything don't
over moralize things
beauty can't exist beauty is not sexual
you can sexualize beauty but beauty in
itself is not all that sexual
you can sexualize it and then once
something's sexualized do you make that
positive or negative you you using words
you can twist anything into anything
you know
i know this though why you like
instructing me okay he has this like he
always talks to me like he's like a
teacher like i'm dumb or something well
you didn't understand what i was talking
about yeah i did know what you were
talking about they want them to cover up
to anime women they want the boobs to be
smaller they say women's boobs are not
there is that really going to happen
though like i said
i kind of feel like you know what the
then all of a sudden a woman jumps in
and goes no women do look like that
she's got that that same rack but the
thing about it is that you always kind
of say oh they say this and that i'm
like one who how many people is this
it's like is anyone listening to these
idiots
no so i never heard that so you know
it's just it's really not that big a
deal i kind of feel like
again and here's going back to what you
say is like oh people can make people
believe anything you take something that
like a couple of people are saying like
some [ __ ] outrageous viewpoint and
you blow it up like they're saying this
and that and the other thing and then
like you know that gets clicks and
everything but it's like how many people
are saying that like 10 people how do we
know well like i said but like some of
the [ __ ] that the numbers that they're
saying is like so ridiculous that it's
like the majority like 99 of people
would never believe that you never
really know what the numbers are because
whatever any numbers and you can twist
anything you know it's just the way
propaganda goes
that's the way you can even go back to
the [ __ ] philosophers of the 1800s
you can take any idea and push it to an
extreme and it'll come right back in on
itself yeah it's just the way it is well
like i said i'm not bothered that's why
i don't even bother with like this kind
of like stupid crap like oh so one
person said we should cover some anime
women up but it's like nobody
it's not like a movement it's not it
might be no it's not though how do you
know that's another thing you have to
know you're jumping to the conclusion
like you know the numbers i don't know
the numbers it's just that
but the thing about it
that's a very very common it's in the
customers it's a very common propaganda
technique there you go to take something
that a couple people have said like a
little fringe and then and they get
bigger they are saying this that and the
other and then they repeat on the news
oh they're saying this and then
everybody's like freaking out about it
it's like look five people are saying
that yeah okay it's like just [ __ ]
chill out so it's that kind of [ __ ] that
i don't know that just like makes me
really angry because it's like that
there's no mask
because
there's no massive movement to do that
don't get angry and then you get like
all these stupid youtube videos and
they're like arguing against that as
though it's some big mass movement it's
not nobody said it was a mass movement
people were
people were just pointing out the
argument and i was pointing the argument
out to you
you the point about it you can take it
well i know that do that with it but i
kind of feel like how many people's
arguments are worth taking seriously or
worth you know giving any brain space to
very very few
and if it's only like five people saying
like this really extreme view oh we
should do this now the other thing it's
like no one's gonna listen to that okay
i'm not gonna listen to that no one's
gonna listen to that
look what
i'm gonna do whatever i want to do
no matter what anybody else is um all
right so am i whatever i want to do so
am i i know
just i'm just i'm not only telling you
that i'm telling the audience that i
don't give a [ __ ] what they say i don't
care if it's literally well you do
because you go on about it all the
[ __ ] times also obviously you forgot
about it every time you talk you every
time you talk you go off on these little
like rants focus all right because he
watches youtube all day yeah so it's
kind of like i watch he gets like this
weird
like skewed version of like what people
are thinking i guess no i don't really
those those are the guys that i have
subscriptions with what they're thinking
but we're talking about a small subject
yeah it's a very tiny subject that no
one else gives a [ __ ] about but i was
just talking about the argument okay it
didn't have anything to do with me i
don't care about what other people think
or what the well i could argue lots of
different arguments
you have pointless arguments about
pointless nothing okay because what does
that solve nothing you just want to
argue for the sake of arguing and that's
dom no it's not dumb yeah it is it's a
skill it's like boxing like what the
[ __ ] yeah your box boxing is also
pointless what are you getting i'm not
trying to kill the other dude you're
just boxing to see who won
and what do you get out of that winnie
okay and what do you get of that winning
what do you get out of that being a
winner
there you go
that's there's really no point to that
there's just really no point okay i
don't i don't see what the point of that
is i just really don't
[Laughter]
i just don't see the point of it
don't see the point of it i have [ __ ] to
do i don't i don't yeah
i can't indulge in all these like
pointless [ __ ] things yeah so how
long we've been on
only an hour and a half damn
only an hour seems like a long time
it does it seems like a long time it
sure does
[Laughter]
do do you want see your show you want me
to leave
no with your willy or something
victor says tom's the type to get
radicalized about conspiracy theories on
youtube oh he absolutely is absolutely
hey
if you've been lied to your whole life
you hear the truth all of a sudden
you're going to say it's a conspiracy or
you hear the truth all of a sudden and
then you just and it's another
conspiracy but you think it's the truth
you know whatever okay
like you know what the truth is
okay
you see like i said he likes to talk to
me like i'm dumb but okay
he talks to me like i'm dumb
i don't know he pinches me like i'm a
cow we talk like looking for my
how are your muscles doing how
[Laughter]
just like stop doing that damn jenny's
getting ready to drive me off the show
yeah no need for me too says my brother
thinks my tattoo makes me part of a cult
that's nice
uh esther says boxing is something i see
on my street i don't really
i don't know if you want a box that's
cool um but
i don't know if it's really i don't know
if i'd really call it a sport or not
is it a sport i guess
zach thank you there are a lot of world
views in the gay community that i think
is a crock of [ __ ] and makes me
embarrassed to be gay by association
gives us a bad name but the thing about
it though is that you can't
i mean
being straight being gay being whatever
you can't like that's a lot of people so
you can't just like generalize oh all
gay people do this all straight people
do that all but all women do this all
men do that like you can't like
generalize about anybody
so
i don't know i wouldn't worry about it
too much i know that like the rest of
the world kind of does that it's like oh
you're a gay dude blah blah blah but i
don't think it's going to be like that
forever i i do kind of feel like people
will eventually just
eventually
just be like hey that person is an
[ __ ] or that person is awesome
instead of just being oh that person is
xyz
which means that
you know what i mean i don't like
stereotyping i just really don't
uh pat says this always happens when
they drink
esther says jenny my boyfriend does the
same thing well that's that's good
picture says i'm not gay i'm a top
look at your hair
it's all [ __ ] willing to change my
hair
no you don't have to okay i just thought
it was like funny if you were to say
change your hair i could change it
i don't really i don't give a [ __ ] if
you change it it doesn't matter to me if
you change your hair or not i'm gonna
change it i know he tries to like do
things like he thinks that make me mad
but i really do i really don't care one
way or the other
so
you know the mozart wig is nice even
though he thinks it's thomas jefferson
yeah okay this time is [ __ ] jefferson
man
it's wolfgang amadeus
mozart it's just thomas jefferson wolfie
for short
so when are you gonna like uh finish
that nocturne mozart
you gonna go like beat up salieri later
david june i'm not gay i sell propane oh
my god
was that show king of the hill
is that still on is king of the hill
still on
i remember that being kind of funny
no need for me says live and let live i
say well yeah it's like i'm not gonna
[ __ ] kill anybody over their freaking
beliefs am i
other than serial killers and maybe that
[ __ ] that did that [ __ ] to sylvia
likens although she's already dead
but
i don't know i wouldn't do that to
somebody
people have all kind of stupid ideas
who am i to tell them they're stupid but
you know
what are you gonna do no king of the
hill has been gone a decade or so this
just goes to show how far i am out of it
i used to i kind of liked king of the
hill
but i haven't seen it like i said that
was another thing that somebody used to
tape for me like a long time ago
and so i don't even realize i know the
simpsons are still on
i think
who'd have thought that that should have
been on this [ __ ] many years later
but uh yeah he says god no jenny but
it's on it reruns yeah i kind of figured
it wasn't on after all this time
uh it's all the guys from back in
jefferson's day
final episode may 6 2010.
which that just goes to show i don't i
don't know like when you get older
um 2010
even though it was 11 years ago
seems like
recent that seems like a long like not
that long ago right
so
you know
so i was like oh it was on for like
longer than i shot and then i thought
tom needs a frilled shirt with that i
got something made of velvet well he he
always says that he has like all this
outfit to go with it but he never no i
don't wear him on a show
i've been warning a long time
why don't you
yeah lazy
yeah okay yeah he's lazy some of that
[ __ ] i could probably fit in anymore
because your arms are too big chest
yeah
probably wouldn't button
although it'd be funny it'd be funny if
you like put that on you should do like
a whole thing
it's a sidetrack show honestly before we
started i had a wig on but it's like i
don't know it didn't look good so i took
it off like 10 minutes before the show
started and just like did my regular
hair
you know what i'm saying
and then he looks at me like well now it
looks even more funny i know what are
you talking about wait what you talking
with that blue one yeah oh that blue
one's cute
i don't know i didn't like it i thought
it made my face look even fatter
but obviously like having it like this
isn't helping if the troll was any
indication
uh what's the topic for friday we are
talking about
bigfoot
we're getting yeah
sasquatch yeah skunk ape
maybe we'll talk about skunk cape and
the is it falc monster it's falc right
falc monster
i mean they're all kind of like big
footy type
creations i haven't done like a really
lot of research about that i've done a
little bit but i still have a couple
days to catch up on some [ __ ]
you know you said you knew a lot about
bigfoot though right yeah
so you can like
help oh yeah okay yeah of course
instead of just me having to like take
the next two days off and like just
research that
because even the [ __ ] wikipedia page
because that's always where i start and
then i kind of like click on all the
links and like watch all the
documentaries and stuff and it's just
kind of like
the bigfoot one is like so intimidating
there's just like it's so long and
there's so much stuff
i'm not watching like all the [ __ ]
all the reality shows like bigfoot
hunters and stuff victor says i [ __ ]
love bigfoot
yeah
we did it
we did a show about just cryptids in
general
that was a long time ago
and we kind of like covered i think we
did like a little bit of like a bigfoot
swamp a
swamp ape skunk ape whatever his [ __ ]
name is we did that but we didn't do
like a whole dedicated like bigfoot show
um you know so
esther says jenny you look
beautiful no matter if you wear a wig
well thank you very much i didn't really
i don't know it just i wasn't feeling it
i wasn't feeling it i was like happy
that i could wear a wig because i could
just like put my [ __ ] dirty ass hair
up in a [ __ ] thing and like put a wig
over it but then when i had it i was
looking at it in the camera and i was
just kind of like
i don't know it's like i'm brushing it
and i'm just kind of like man it's just
not it's not working for me today it's
not working they're saying that
that i have to channel baby sass
i don't remember i can't channel baby's
ass i've missed well you have to watch
the movie again yeah you have to watch
the movie again
to channel baby's ass no you don't even
remember what i didn't channel babysass
i just talked about babysits well i know
but i'm just saying if you watch the
movie again maybe sas doesn't seem to
could
channel baby well just in the behavior
you don't have to talk yeah
you could just channel baby sides
you could just channel
uh yeah thornton says supposedly alien
activity coincides with bigfoot
sightings yeah we i might get into that
a little bit because i do kind of feel
like as bigfoot
lore has expanded let's call it that um
it's kind of like
leaked into other
paranormal
topics as in
maybe bigfoot is from another planet
or
which you know
no offense to anybody but
i kind of think that's uh largely
[ __ ]
uh thank you zach you guys should do a
show on francis farmer the actress oh
you know what we totally should because
and i'm going to write that down because
i want to do a show about
now wasn't she put in a in an asylum
because i kind of wanted to do a show
about
or back in the old days
when
the ladies were like mouthing off or
like doing [ __ ] you didn't like and you
could just like throw them in an asylum
uh yeah like what happened was like
rosemary kennedy and stuff like that
like she got like
lobotomized and all this other kind of
crap so i kind of wanted to do a show
about that eventually
um so i'm gonna write that down i'll put
that in the poll
because that's like a really that would
be a really good uh topic
to talk about
actually we were watching
i was watching something
that show lore
it's like an it it's on amazon prime and
it's like this show that's kind of like
it's based on the lore podcast which is
really good but they did a show about
their shows are kind of like all over
the place but they did a show about um
kind of mental health and lobotomies in
particular and they talked about uh
rosemary kennedy on that show and i was
like oh [ __ ] we should do a [ __ ] show
about that or about that whole
era you know what i mean because the
show was mostly about like the doctor
that came up with oh hey let's
stick a thing up people in people's eye
sockets and like scramble their brains a
little bit and it'll like cure the
depression
which
maybe in a few cases it did but in other
cases um maybe not so happy outcomes
just saying um yeah it was a whole thing
yeah victor says bigfoot is bleed
through from a parallel universe
yes yeah we um
do you remember that show we did it was
a [ __ ] i can't remember what show
that was but it was a while back
we did a show
with a couple of guys who were like
super super into bigfoot
and
we were talking about other [ __ ] we
weren't talking about bigfoot we're not
like bigfoot experts or anything so we
were like talking about probably like
poltergeist or whatever
and
it seemed like to me that they were
trying to steer everything toward
bigfoot
the extra dimensional bigfoot angle i
kind of feel like they were because they
kind of like asked some like pointed
questions they were kind of like trying
to go in that direction like dude we're
not even talking about that so i do kind
of feel like there's this
like subset of the paranormal
uh gang that's trying to like make
bigfoot and they're trying to like push
it into other
like poltergeist stuff like alien stuff
thank you zach the movie about her life
with jessica lange is a favorite and
turns out she had a talk show in
indianapolis and she's buried right here
in fishers yeah i kind of want to do a
show about that because
i don't know that's that's a really
interesting like uh topic to me
um
saunders says don't be grumpy tom he is
being grumpy not being grumpy yeah you
are no no you're both strong characters
so sometimes it gets louder yeah
um
no the the problem with the [ __ ] big
the paranormal [ __ ] bigfoot
there's a reason why they're doing that
they got guys who have whole shows
focused around [ __ ] bigfoot at least
they did i don't know i don't know if
they're still surviving doing what it
was they were doing
i mean how much money can you make off
bigfoot a bigfoot stream
maybe a lot i don't know but uh yeah i'm
not um
the iq was rock bottom on those [ __ ]
shows
they would basically say anything
and people were giving them money
and
i was like man
i was on these shows and i'm like going
this [ __ ] was a [ __ ] show well i
kind of got mad because
i kind of feel like we got invited on
there to talk about a particular thing
like usually it was about poltergeist
because that's kind of like what we had
talked about in the past so we get
invited on some shows i'm not naming
them i don't even remember what they're
calling but we got invited on some
paranormal shows
to talk about poltergeist ostensibly and
then when you get on there like you kind
of talk about it and then they'd start
like trying to channeling you down
towards like the bigfoot the reason why
they're doing this paranormal
extra-dimensional spiritual bigfoot
[ __ ]
is because the footprints have dried up
people are having [ __ ] sightings that
report a sighting
and there's no photographs of any kind
of footprints left behind bigfoot the
whole [ __ ] legend was based upon
big feet in footprints left behind right
those aren't around
those footprints were faked yeah guys
had [ __ ] special shoes that had those
all right
so those aren't around anymore
so you have to say to explain
to explain away the footprints you're
saying well it's not a real it's not a
real uh
creature it's a paranoid they're trying
to go paranormal with it and savage
explains the lack of the [ __ ]
footprints i get it
i guess
well it's just kind of like look i get
it okay if you're like in the paranormal
realm
and you're trying to make money off of
[ __ ] which like i said i'm not
denigrating like everybody gonna make
money okay everybody gotta eat everybody
get paid their rent i'm not
judging
um so if that's kind of your whole bread
and butter
and
your whole shtick is bigfoot
and nobody has found any like physical
evidence of bigfoot like recently
then you're gonna like write a book
saying well the reason nobody has found
physical evidence of bigfoot is because
he's actually an extra dimensional being
and therefore doesn't leave any
footprints or doesn't leave any scat for
like magical reasons
and people will eat that [ __ ] up
you just have to keep you know i'm to be
honest and please i'm sure there i'm
sure that this is out there
i would be shocked if somebody hadn't
written a book
saying that jack the ripper
was an
extra dimensional being yeah
star trek said that
they did yeah so it is so it would
surprise me even more if somebody hadn't
written a book trying to like cash in on
that [ __ ] because well that's why they
never caught him because he just
popped out of that dimension
killed a bunch of prostitutes and then
popped up back into another dimension
and went to another dimension and killed
their prostitutes instead so i kind of
feel like please tell me that there's a
book like that because i'm sure there is
i would bet a substantial amount of
money that there's already a book like
that
because that totally sounds like
something somebody would write oh my god
is there a good movie about bigfoot the
first
uh boggy creek is okay
i've heard willow creek is good
uh that's
oh that's larry fessenden i want to say
but i haven't seen it so i can't like
recommend it because i haven't seen it
but i've heard that it's good so maybe
some other people can give you some
recommendations
but uh jack the ripper was a bigfoot
yeah it's like totally there's like a
totally you could totally cross over
the whole two [ __ ]
has anybody done that
somebody's done that
nowadays they had to have they had to
have
the question is is there a bigfoot
we're going to talk about that on the
next show
yeah don't waste it
there could be an o-ring pending
and to be honest of all the paranormal
things like topics
bigfoot is probably the one well bigfoot
and aliens are kind of the one i'm the
most like met on because i'm like yeah
that probably could or something like
that could exist i'm not saying it does
i'm just saying it's more plausible than
some of the other [ __ ] that's all i'm
saying
you know yeah
although in this day and age like the
more we have satellites that's what i
mean the more the more time that goes on
like the less likely that it is right
because you would think that if
something like that existed
that somebody would have come up with it
by now
there's a lot of problems
similar problems
similar problems with the loch ness
monster
there's no loch ness monster impossible
there would have to be a breeding
population i kind of feel like it's
probably just a bunch of eels
to be honest with you what they're
seeing is they're making up stories well
that too but i'm just saying if they see
anything i think it's like an eel or
something there's
with the loch ness monster you would
have to if it was big you'd have to have
a breeding population
so there had to be [ __ ] 20 of them
and they wouldn't be down in the bottom
of a lake that doesn't have much
vegetation or not much fish in it they'd
be laying up on the [ __ ] bank taking
sun
they'd be everywhere because they don't
know they're elusive yeah yeah this
whole elusive creatures no
those don't exist in in nature it would
be like a bunch of dead we don't care if
humans are looking at us or not
elephants or whales they'd just be up on
the surface going oh man the sun feels
good
so
no there's no
there's no loch ness monster
although there were lake monsters
in europe
but they were catfish or big ass [ __ ]
bass that could swallow a man which are
scary enough yeah and that was during
the medieval period
and you know uh oh [ __ ]
well what's his name jeremy wade proved
that
yeah he caught some horrifying yeah
if you guys haven't seen river monsters
holy crap and he'll show some old wood
cuts
where a [ __ ] big old pile of corn and
then a [ __ ] cow
and then the [ __ ] catfish or
they're all the same size sitting next
to each other and
and they weren't icons that's how big
they were
some of those catfish could get [ __ ]
huge
but it takes hundreds of years
well yeah and a catfish can't get to be
150 years old anymore
because we have fishing rods rod and
reel ketchup by the time they're [ __ ]
20 years old
but they didn't have that in the
medieval period they only had nets
and once a fish got to a certain size
you couldn't catch it in a net
the only way to catch it was to drain
the pond and that's when they're
reporting finding those things
after they drained a drain adrenaline
see that's why like all those paintings
back in the day that showed like the
catfish they were the same size as a cow
like even though jeremy wade never
caught a catfish that was exactly the
same size as a cow close he caught some
that were pretty goddamn close so
i mean he caught some horrifying [ __ ]
and that's like nowadays yeah so i kind
of feel like back in the old days when
we didn't have like all the overfishing
and like fish finders and like you said
rotten reels and stuff like that yeah
i'm sure they got like way bigger
so yeah
i don't find that hard to believe at all
it was a different time
people people lived to be 70 80 90 100
years old
and they think that that's [ __ ] old
when they think of a fish they're
thinking oh maybe it is five years old
six years old yeah those are the fish
you were catching now with the rod and
reel
but before rod and reel of fish could
live to be 150 years old
i talked about this before
people think that you're supposed to
grow old and die that that's like a
normal thing
humans for a human it is but the hu
human genome is not very good
it was not selected to for long life
other animals can live to be nearly 200
years old but like look at them big like
galapagos tortoises and stuff and they
never show any and alligators they never
really show any signs of age they just
get bigger
about you know 120 we're not even sure
how long how old the alligator lives
no alligator has ever died of old age
well not that they know of not that
we've not in captivity and not in
captivity not in captivity which is a
different situation right they've never
died of old age um
what they die of normally is starvation
they get so big they can't fuel their
own metabolisms
but they're millions and millions of
years old that they come from a time
when there were big creatures everywhere
so theoretically maybe something like an
alligator might live to be about 250 300
years old before it's killed yeah which
wouldn't be weird for them it would be
that weird back then and in nature
that's not that weird because it's like
look trees which aren't you know people
don't think of like trees and animals in
the same thing but it's like it's all
along the same spectrum
trees can live hundreds 500 a thousand
years
you know what i mean so it's not that
crazy
theoretically some of these fish turtles
alligators
maybe live to 200 300 years old if they
have
the food supply
well that's kind of the thing like the
bigger you get the more you have to eat
to maintain that body size and the
oldest alligator that's ever been around
which is above 100 was just as lively
and and vivacious at his old age of 100
and something as they are when they're
little so they're not growing old and
dying like a human would or other
animals
they're just getting bigger really
that's what it is
and it's [ __ ] their hormones and
they're just their dna is is built for
that
theoretically you could do that to a
human
growth is life
metabolism is about growth
if the metabolism is going well it will
just continue to grow
if it's not going well it'll shrink
it'll get smaller and die you look at
old people they get osteoporosis they
start to shrink their muscle mass goes
down and then they die
you look at another dude like jacqueline
he's bumping anavar he's like 90
something years old he's still [ __ ]
slow looks good
he died eventually though
but you know it's just
age
growing old and dying is a human
phenomenon
this might explain why you have these
old legends of dragons [ __ ] ancient
dragons living to be a [ __ ] 500 years
old
hundreds of years old these old ancient
wise dragons down in the earth with
[ __ ] bunch of treasure and [ __ ]
maybe people knew about alligators that
had lived for [ __ ]
300 [ __ ] gigantic 300 year old
[ __ ] alligator 400 year old alligator
might be 30 40 feet long huge you know
feeding off people and [ __ ] cattle
and [ __ ] in the area and you know people
have been talking about that giant
alligator for [ __ ] generations and
from that came the idea of dragons
which it fits
you know that's really not i mean that's
not that crazy because
i mean they've caught ones like i said
if you go to the [ __ ] alligator farm
in saint augustine
and they have gomek
uh who was a crocodile they cut him in
new guinea
and he's dead now like they stuffed him
but i mean i saw him when he was alive
so he was alive in my lifetime
and that [ __ ] was like 22 feet long
they caught him
back in the 70s or 60s or something like
that i can't remember when and he's like
[ __ ]
gigantic
so if he hadn't been caught
if he had continued to live in the wild
would he have just gotten bigger and
bigger and bigger
over the decades
and then like you said over generations
would people have just like seen
glimpses of him it's like because even
as he is now
um you know stuffed and he's like he's
scary he's big
and it's like so if he'd gotten even
bigger than that like over the
generations and people would like tell
stories about him like
[ __ ] i saw this thing and it was like
this big [ __ ] giant
you know because crocodilians act
alligator stuff like that are like
really really scary especially when they
get that big and they can [ __ ] bite
your arm off
so
i don't know i don't feel i don't feel
like that's too far out of bounds you
know
for that legend to have arisen around
them those animals all came from a time
when creatures were bigger
so there's more meat to go around
there's more and there were more animals
so there's more food
like look at the megalodon giant shark
yeah
could be that a great white might get
that big all right if there was enough
food
yeah because that's the thing right like
you really have to they have to be in an
environment
there's enough to like sustain their
body size and we find a megalodon and
you go that [ __ ] giant teeth
the size of a [ __ ] human hand
all right huge [ __ ] shark
for all you know that's a 800 year old
shark
you don't know how old yeah i don't
really know so that might be
it might be that there's not any
difference
between a megalodon and a great white
it's just that the megalodons you're
finding are 800 years old because
there's a [ __ ] ton of fish
and they can just eat eat and eat and
grow and grow and grow their own [ __ ]
they're they're on [ __ ]
basically biological [ __ ] norm
natural biological [ __ ] anabolic
steroids they're just continuing to grow
and grow and grow
they don't grow weak they go stronger
the more food that they eat the stronger
they get so they're not growing old
very plausible
very plausible captain blair says a guy
down south stopped hunting turtles for
soup
because he started finding musket balls
and then stone arrowheads lodged in
their shells
plausible but
the thing is those a musket ball is just
a piece of
lead
and
down south you have primitive hunting
season which i i did it all the time
humble muzzle loaders 100 with 50 and 54
caliber muzzle loaders
so just because you find them just
because you find a musket ball you're
calling it a musket ball all right it's
not a musket ball it's a [ __ ] muzzle
loading rifle but you can get muskets
that's just a smooth bore shotgun really
with
muzzle loaded smoothbore shotgun
um so just because he's finding that in
there doesn't mean that it's ancient
that might be modern because
but still those tortoises do live along
the tourist lives a long time 150 years
no problem
no problem yeah and same thing with
snapping turtles we used to pull
big snapping turtle was that big
head on it the size of a small dog
[ __ ] weighed almost a 17 80 pounds
[ __ ] heavy ass snapping turtle
but we had a tendency to clear snappers
out of [ __ ]
out of stuff they're a nuisance they eat
up fish
so the less snapping turtles you have
in your pond the more hey they gotta eat
fish you're gonna have well you're
trying to kill you them
we were killing snapping turtles when
they were little though you don't kill
them so much when they're big when
they're little to kill them
they'd be sitting up on top of
sitting up on top of [ __ ] little logs
and [ __ ] up around the banks and you
go out there a little 22 and you spend
all day long shooting little turtles you
might get 50 of them in an hour you know
all day long you're shooting them little
[ __ ] turtles
come back the next day and you'll find
up around the bank where their noses
shot off and pieces of them shut off
those are the ones that survived the
first wave of shooting
because sometimes you see little heads
popping up you're trying to shoot the
head
and you're trying to clear the snappers
out of the [ __ ]
pond so
so they don't kill your stock because
you've stocked that pond
any pond we had rights on we stocked it
and so you paid for those fish that are
you're gonna fish out of there you try
to get the snappers out because they're
eating your fish it's not their fish
they even pay for them [ __ ]
none of those pot none of those ponds
that we had in mississippi that we were
doing this with were natural ponds
either they were all artificial ponds
you just get send your friends down
there to dig it
and it'll fill it with water fill it
with some water and it'll just continue
to fill
and the birds bring all that stuff in
the eggs and the [ __ ] turtles get in
it and [ __ ] so
some people are like well you're
destroying nature not really we created
it
because those ponds were all artificial
and then we would all stock them
with the
bluegill and brim and bass and [ __ ]
catfish and then the fit and then the
birds are bringing more a lot of people
don't realize that but
birds come in with dried up fish eggs
and in their
feathers and they land in the water and
just they they're transporting fish from
one pond to the next all the time
well yeah that's how come like little
ponds that have still have like fish
instructions yeah they come from a birds
uh pat says what do you think about the
rumors of giant alligators in the sewers
i remember seeing like those uh movies
from the 80s like that movie alligator
which i think came out in 81 82
somewhere around that like scared the
crap out of me but
honestly i think
the sewers are too cold um alligators
are they don't like cold water they
don't like because like most reptiles
they were saying that was new york i
think right
like most reptiles um you know
alligators are cold-blooded so they need
uh
you know and lizards everything like
that is like this in florida if it's
winter time and it's like under
60 50 degrees
they will pretty much go into stasis
and the same thing happens with
alligators so i think it's kind of too
cold in the sewers
too and there's not enough food also and
there wouldn't be a breeding population
so i kind of feel like that's probably
[ __ ] um you know but it was a good
urban legend because the urban legend
was back in the old days um everybody
was like selling like little baby
alligators for pets which i think they
did do like in a limited capacity for a
little while and some people like oh
word so you know they getting too big
we're gonna flush them down the toilet i
don't believe that
um i think they'd probably just like let
them go somewhere
which they would die anyway up there and
up that yeah in in a cooler climate they
would die yeah
alligators crocodiles stuff like that
like i said they're cold-blooded um
which means that their blood is the same
temperature is the outdoor temperature
so when it's too cold they just go into
stasis i used to have um
i had i've had pet iguanas i've had pet
geckos uh i've had many reptilians for
pets
when it's cold outside
they they don't die but they
just go into like a
a weird like coma state yeah they don't
move
because it's not warm enough for them to
like they can't move heat up it's not
warm enough for them to heat up that's
why you see in florida you see like when
it's warm out like in the morning like
all the little lizards come out and they
just like sit there they're soaking all
the sun in yeah to like heat up for the
day like for the activity
because if they don't have that then
they can't really do anything they just
kind of sit there so alligators and [ __ ]
are kind of the same so just saying
so i don't think they could live and
like the sewers
especially not up north they would die
or they would just be sitting there not
doing anything not enough food up there
[Music]
all right i gotta pee if anything if it
if an alligator ever ended up in new
york
and ended up in its sewer system
that alligator would find its way out of
that system eventually
it would probably
i believe if i remember correctly an
alligator can make can survive in salt
water
it would get out into the ocean slowly
migrate south where it was warmer
if it it it would probably be killed in
that in that
journey but it would try
so if you had a lot of them like as the
as the myth and the legend goes
if you had a lot of them like say
several thousand of them
within the time frame of this so-called
legend
some of them would have made the journey
but they would just make it down south
by the time they got halfway it'd be
warm enough they could hang out a little
bit they'd eventually get down into
florida
they love it here
i mean you can just go on youtube and
look you know just google you know just
search up you know [ __ ]
florida alligator
and you'll see huge alligators walking
through traffic
in miami
and people just have fun you know
they're not killing them or
or anything they're not pestering the
[ __ ]
alligator alligator just walking up on
all fours his belly off the ground
walking proud amongst all the cars going
right through the intersection people
honking and waving
you know
then it'll get down into look we have
little culverts with [ __ ] little
artificial irrigation rivers that'll go
in there
and people don't bother
and um
as big as they are as as big and as
scary as they are they they are
dangerous
but as big as they are there's very
little problems with them um
an alligator will walk right by you
and ignore you well it depends you know
well no if you're around if you're in
its territory around a pond
around eggs
there might be a problem
i heard they're they'll defend those
eggs well yeah but there's videos of
them walking right through traffic in
downtown miami well like i said they're
walking right and just run across the
road walk around yeah and walk right
right past the person
yeah they don't care they're not like
they're not looking to eat you no
it's just i mean you're not really their
main food source they're they're trying
to get where they're they're trying to
get to that next body of water
but the thing about it though is that
it's a wild animal and you don't really
know you don't i wouldn't approach one
no
not much i kind of feel like yeah
i'd be more worried like i said i've
been more worried about my kids or about
my pets
um because they don't really know and
they'll just like fart around at the
side of the thing and like if in you
know a pond or whatever and an alligator
would be like hey free food
and i'll jump up because i have seen
like some people's little dogs
and cats and children
and um you know so it does happen
so you do have to like watch
it's not super common
but
it happens often enough that probably
you shouldn't like let your kids or pets
like hang out like in any like little
ponds around your neighborhood i
wouldn't well there's there's easy ways
to clear it
um
at night if you go up with a flashlight
and just if it's a small pond like we
got little drainage ponds everywhere
let's go up there with a flashlight at
night and shine it on the pond if you
don't see any eyes there isn't any
alligators in there
because at night they're they all
surface at night during the day they're
watching they're watching they're just
their eyes still just eyes
and you'll see these [ __ ] yellow
reflections
during the daytime they're hidden
they'll they'll stay submerged a lot
so it doesn't work for the daytime but
at night time just go down there with a
flashlight and sweep sweep it
if you don't see any eyes then there's
no alligators in it
i mean the ponds you can do that
regularly yes they'll change because
they move from pond to pond yeah because
the thing about it is that like in our
neighborhood like i said we live in like
this kind of gated community we're kind
of near the back
fence like the back entrance
and there's kind of a big pond
in the back and like there's a sign
there that says like hey like watch for
alligators
i've never seen any alligators in that
particular pond
but
i've seen birds there i've seen deer
i've seen like a bunch of other animals
i don't know but like the pond that's
right by our that's like two
backyards down
i think is too small to sustain an
alligator but i mean because that's
pretty small that pond which one the one
that's that pookie sometimes likes to
look into it's not deep
no it's just like it's not really even a
pond it's kind of like a big
it's like a glorious artifact
it's a drain train it's a drainage yeah
place to drain for it's to prevent
flooding they're all over floor uh these
florida all over these plant communities
they all have these little [ __ ]
artificial ponds to drain drain off
excess water
you can fish in them
they say you can fish them
i've seen people they're fishing every
now and then yeah
but now the pond that's like kind of
like i don't have turtles in them though
yeah i've seen snapper turtles changing
ponds yeah
that big round
yeah but the thing about it is that the
pond that's up on
the path
like remember if you go like on the path
and you go like a little bit farther
like out toward 46a and there's like
that big kind of swampy pond
i've never seen an alligator in there
but i've heard them lots of times
because they make that it's like a croak
noise yeah that mom makes the croaky
noise like calling for her babies like
she'll get bro
it's like that kind of noise like i've
heard that lots of times
so i know that there's alligators in
there i just haven't seen any of them
but i know they're there
so but pookie doesn't go to that one
because that's far away the thing is
there's a word about alligators she i i
don't the whole time i've been here i
haven't seen an alligator
not here
but
but i've seen at least five bears
black bears yeah we see bears all the
time there's all time bears and raccoons
it's weird because i've seen alligators
more i saw alligators more when i was
growing up in daytona
i saw an alligator
run across the street
well like my house was a couple like was
in this neighborhood that was right by
our elementary school
and alligator ran across that street
that went from my neighborhood to the
elementary school and got run over
so i saw that i also saw an alligator
run across
uh
92 us-92 when i was going from like
daytona to dell to uh
deland
and i was driving that road and i saw an
alligator just like booking it like
right across i was like huh look at that
there he goes and like some other car
like it was a big one too and like some
other car like almost hit him like on
the other side because it's like a
divided highway
and uh so yeah so i feel like i saw more
of them like when i lived in daytona i
haven't seen that i haven't seen any in
the wild yeah since i've moved here but
yeah like you said bears we see bears we
see bears all the time yeah we see bears
all the time
um
those bears were big
yeah well it looked to me while i was
[ __ ] working on the bike came and
looked at me in the [ __ ] garage in
the garage
he was big that was a big bear maybe
400 pounds
yeah
stood uh
set up to here his [ __ ] back of his
shoulders a big big bear bigger than a
man
now and i think it might have been the
same one that was sitting in the
driveway when we came home it might have
been it was bigger than a man
yeah it was a big [ __ ] bear big old
and he saw the car he wasn't scary
though he was like he was sitting on his
back feet like that with his arms and he
saw us he's like sitting in our driveway
and we're pulling in he goes oh [ __ ]
rolls over well i guess i can't stay
here yeah
i was gonna just gonna sleep here for
the night but no no the car came
oh yeah
i felt bad
he wasn't angry though he was just kind
of like well gotta move on
and then he like kind of wanted to
approach you
not really like not unless you're
[ __ ] with them uh esther asked how
puke and beige were
they're good they're doing good yeah
pookie's being did i did i say about
like the [ __ ] that that poop did the
other morning
what we do
she likes it like
i go in the closet in the morning
because we have like a big walk-in
closet
and if she hears somebody get up or she
hears somebody get out of the shower and
she knows that they're getting going in
the walk-in closet she like runs she's
like oh my god it's closet time it's
closet time because she's just like she
loves the walk-in closet
and she loves when somebody's in there
with her
so i go in there and i'm just like and
then if you don't go in there
immediately like sometimes i get out of
the shower and then i go like put lotion
or some [ __ ] on my face or whatever and
it's like she just like stands at the
closed door like are you coming or
what's the deal so i'm like okay i'm
coming so i go in there and like i sit
on there sit on the floor in the closet
and like i'm just petting her and she's
like rubbing on my feet and she's like
mommy whatever and then like she's
laying there
she does this weird thing where it's
like she likes to kind of lay a little
bit away from you so it's kind of like
i'm my own like cool little person but
it's like also i want to hang out with
you so i'm like okay whatever so i'm
like petting her
and then
she gave me this weird like side long
kind of look she gave me this little
shifty
yeah she me side eye is what she did and
i thought it was like really funny so i
like gave her side eye back right i was
kind of like what are you looking at me
all shifty like that for and then she's
like whatever and then she did it again
she's like sad long and i was like why
are you looking at me like that and i
gave her like a little side long and
then she got super mad and then she like
whipped her head around gave me like
these big huge round eyes and she goes
like that she made like that noise i
mean like she was really mad that i was
like looking at her like shifty she
didn't like that i was
mimicking her facial expressions i guess
i told you to stop
yeah she was like stop that because yeah
that's what she does she makes this
little noise like she doesn't open her
mouth but it's like this so i can't
really do it but it
she says
yeah
like stop doing that i don't know where
tila's been victor she hasn't been here
in about a year
she lives in san francisco man
san francisco's having a crime wave who
knows maybe she moved maybe she moved
she was talking about moving
what do you look at me for i don't know
no i just said she was talking about
moving
maybe
i haven't heard anything from her
uh
somebody said crawl is a good alligator
movie i actually quite liked crawling
actually we saw that in the theater i
think
now that i'm uh thinking about it
that was you know fairly accurate
uh
sorensen said i got bit by a stamping
turtle was trying to help the ungrateful
bastard across the street
oh
we've tried it i don't
i don't think i've ever been bitten by a
turtle i do every time i see them in the
road though it's like you got to stop
and like help them because they're so
slow
and you know some [ __ ] is just going to
run up over
you know what i mean yeah
david jean says tila's been at my place
don't worry my dude
her husband know
does her husband know about victor said
maybe she's interdimensional when she
went home
with bigfoot that's probably a catfish a
cow
the white dude hold on somebody come
again who's trying to get in trying to
get him pooped pookie's like a kid
where'd she go was it her no
sounds like her but she didn't i didn't
hear anything last time i saw her she
was sleeping on the chairs out there
yeah i thought she was like sleeping up
in the bowl yeah
thorn says i have eight cats and three
dogs and two opossums oh
we've been talking about
i don't know i don't know if we're gonna
do this but we have been talking about
getting poke
um another kitty that's like more of her
age
maybe i don't know
we're talking about it
because beijing is older
and she doesn't want blue and they kind
of hang out together sorta
but
beijing is usually just kind of like
[ __ ] that baby yeah she still thinks of
her as a baby because beijing is like
what 12 13 yeah
so she even though puke is like four
she's kind of like yeah she's a baby i
don't want to play with her
so she like grudgingly puts up with her
but
it's for sure grudging well no drink
yeah
so i don't know we were talking about it
it's like maybe we should get another
kitten that'll like i don't know if we
should get a kitten
i feel like we should get another cat
that's pookie's age
because
i don't know man like jackson galaxy
says if you're gonna adopt a cat
adopt two cats that are the same age so
they can play with each other
and i don't know i think that's a good
idea because i kind of feel like a lot
of people don't realize that cats are
like kind of social
um so if they don't have another cat
around their age that they can play with
then they will crawl up your ass and you
will never get anything done
so
and i'm not saying like pookie's not
like that she's i mean
she likes attention i will say that like
you know if i'm in here working and it's
like daddy's not paying attention to her
then she will totally come in here and
like jump on all my laptops and try to
crawl behind my monitor and like be like
hey i'm going to push all your books off
the desk and let's like just please pay
attention to me like she jumps up on my
oh and here she is right now i'm just
talking about jabuki
but you know she's not like
hi
hey
what's up see look oh she's on the show
i was just talking about you wanna
attention poke and there you are she's
like daddy's not in the chair so i'm
just gonna sit in it
yeah
would you like if i well hey would you
like if i got you a friend
you want a little friend that's the same
age as you
yeah look what she's doing oh she's back
yeah or you're back
i was just talking about that because i
was talking about
she's like i'm just gonna sit in your
chair [ __ ] it you get about the show
look
look everybody's asking about you
everybody's asking she's like i don't
care but yeah so
i don't know so we were talking about
like tom's like maybe we should get a
little kitten and i was like see i don't
know how that would go though because i
kind of feel like if we got like a
little kitten kitten
um like you know as little as pookie was
when we first got her because she was
only like six or eight weeks old when we
first got her and i was kind of like i
don't know maybe she'd beat up on the
kitten i don't really know how that
would work
but
i don't know i kind of feel like getting
somebody the same age as her
might be good because then they could
kind of like
play together
because like i said her in beijing they
have like an uneasy it's better than it
was when we first when she was little
like now that she's kind of
mostly fully grown
beijing will put up with her but only to
an extent because pookie is still like
very very playful
and she's kind of like hey i'm gonna
like jump on your fluffy butt and
beijing's like yeah i'm not having it
and she'll just like hiss and like
[ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] this
why like why are you doing this to me
she does that kind of [ __ ] so
i don't know so i don't know how it's
gonna go but i don't know it's something
that we've been discussing can we really
have like three cats in the house
i don't know we'll see how it goes i
mean
i don't mind
i love cats so
cats are awesome
more cats the better but i don't know i
don't know if pookie i don't know how
pooky will react how will you react
pokey
she knows i'm talking about her she
knows what her name is how will you
react if i got you another cat that was
like your same size and same size that
age
how do you think she would react i don't
know
i'm not really sure either
i'm not probably have fun she doesn't
seem to be very
concerned about it
pat says um aren't cats very territorial
though
some of them are but they seem to be
pookie is not territorial
um
[Music]
pookie is kind of like
it's kind of hard to explain she's sort
of like um
she's not like afraid because like she
when she came in and we already had
beijing and beijing had been here for
like many years
she was just kind of she wasn't
obnoxious about it but she also wasn't
afraid to
kind of carve out her own space
type of thing you know what i'm saying
so
but i'm not i don't
really know how she would react to a
younger cat
pookie i don't know how she would react
i know how beijing would react she'd be
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] because that's how
she does everything but pookie i don't
know she might love it she might hate it
i'm not really sure maybe bring pookie
with you when you go to the shelter
what's she talking about what shelter
shittama
if you're going to get another cat oh
okay and like let pookie pick the cat
out which actually would probably be a
good idea
i kind of like like i said i love to get
kittens because i like to raise them
because like i said you know i liked
raising her from little
but
i don't know i kind of feel like it'd be
better to get somebody that was like to
get a cat that was like her age
you know i just i don't know i just feel
like she needs somebody to play with
but
because
beijing won't most of the time
beijing's kind of like aloof
all right so uh did anybody else have
any more questions any more topics that
you want us to get on
how long have you been streaming
two hours and 19 minutes okay pat says i
was asking because i thought pookie
would constantly be fighting with this
new one see that's the thing i don't
know she would or not i kind of feel
like no but
she likes to like
she likes socialize she likes to
socialize she's a very social cat yeah
um you know she'll she'll hang out with
uh with tom and she'll she likes to
wrestle
she just likes she likes attention yeah
so
if there was another cat that was her
age that she could play with i think she
might dig it i don't know because they
could like play together and they could
hang out
and because she's kind of like looking
to us to do that all the time
which like i said that's fine but
i don't know
like i said i kind of feel like people
feel like cats are these
sort of isolated creatures and they're
really not they're more social than you
think they're more social than i mean
they're not as social as dogs maybe but
they still
i think they still benefit from having
other cats their age around that they
can
interact with
you know
uh terry says get a black bomb bae cat
they're just like dogs pookie is kind of
like a dog also
you know
victor says
i'm a dog person but i wouldn't be
opposed to having a dog and a cat and
honestly like sometimes dogs and cats
get along i don't see how
like pookie is very
she's still a cat but she's very
dog-like
or what most people perceive is like
being dog-like she kind of follows us
around she wants to be like involved in
everything we're doing
she's like hey what are you doing she's
not real aloof beijing is
but pookie is definitely not aloof no
she definitely wants to be involved
in whatever it is that you're doing
she's very interactive she's very
talkative
she's just kind of like
you know like i said i i get out of the
shower and go in the [ __ ] closet in
the morning she's like come on
we gotta like sit down and
do this whole ritual she has like these
whole
i don't know she has like all these
rituals that she does
tom gets out of the shower in the
evening and it's like she's she wherever
she is in the house she goes can i see
her like run to the closet yeah because
she hears you get out yeah she wants to
play with the towel she wants tom to
like throw the wet towel on her yeah
and then she's underneath the towel
she's funny she loves being underneath
the towel i don't know she'll just like
sit there
like you throw the towel on her and
she'll just be like okay
and then she'll like lay there well it's
just kind of like if you're making the
bed
she'll jump up on the bed and she'll
just like sit on the bed and then like
you throw the comforter over here and
she's like yeah all right
she just likes being under the under the
comforter she likes being involved
in whatever it is that you're doing i
don't know if she like
knows
but you know
uh terry says black and white tuxedo
cats are the smartest of all the house
cat breeds
i've heard that also
i mean she is um
she's just
she's a manx
she's a little gray kitty
i've heard megs are pretty smart too
i don't know i used to have a black and
white one and they were pretty smart so
i will say that
donald bob says tom just finished
watching red sun with charles bronson on
your recommendation good film yeah
glad you finally got a round of them
that's a good film
samurai's samurai film in the old west
yeah
i remember that movie i remember that
movie
i showed that to a japanese guy who was
a [ __ ] online friend of mine i
recommended it to him and he was like oh
man that was great he loved that but he
didn't know that that movie existed
it's forgotten in japan man they're
saying it came out how many movies that
people forgot that it came out in japan
also that that actor was a famous actor
in japan at that time
and
japan
you know
they liked westerns but their version of
a western was the samurai movie
well it's a similar
similar thing sure
so uh when that movie came out there was
it was i think there was slightly some
joint venture
between that and a japanese studio that
released it subtitled
and uh in japan and it was it was like a
minor hit in japan when it came out too
i think it was in the 60s late 60s early
70s
good movie
no need for me to says man jenny you're
making me miss my cat i'm sorry i mean
yeah
pookie and beige they're like our babies
you know so it's kind of like
and pookie for sure is kind of like
a human kid except with fur
i mean she acts like a kid
esther if you like samurai movie see red
sun
it was um
i don't know if it's streaming
it used to be pl it used to be you could
watch for free on youtube
somebody had a
a copy of it posted it was a pretty good
copy
it's just it's about a japanese samurai
in the old west
and he [ __ ]
teams up with a bank robber played by
charles bronson and they try to go back
to capture the emperor's sword they got
stole from a diplomat that's pretty cool
thank you david june what did he say get
two betas one tank thunderdome style
winner stays oh man don't do that
because honestly
um i think i won one of those betta
those siamese fighting fish they used to
call them yeah i won one at a carnival
my dad was like really into fish tanks
when i was younger so we had like a
whole bunch of fish tanks in our house
we had one full of neons we had one like
somalis we had all kind of stuff
and we had one with a betta in it
and
it was kind of like when we were little
kids and we didn't know any better it's
like hey let's hold the mirror up to the
bed it's like we'll watch him fight like
and his little [ __ ] fins go up and
he's like oh it's another one oh i'm
gonna get it and he's like oh look he's
like banging the glass but in a way it's
like i feel really really bad about that
now i would never do that to like an
animal that's that's [ __ ] up david i
saw the zad to eat your films there's a
million of them i saw we have the uh we
have the special edition yeah uh
all the movies right no well some of the
movies no we don't we don't have you're
getting
we have all of the uh oh lone wolf and
cubs that's what i was thinking we don't
have all those
the southwestern movies because there's
26 of them there's 26 26 i was thinking
which is only six movies for about a
hundred bucks you can get a ball it
means that's wichi that's like a bag
yeah i haven't seen them all but i've
seen like most of them
the problem with that to each movies
they're all pretty good
but it gets repetitive you got 26 movies
there's not much you can do it's almost
like watching a damn television series
it starts to
starts to be kind of like the same thing
over and over again
that's what i've heard
it takes forever to get through all 26
movies though
yeah some are better than others i mean
i like that concept though yeah like i
said if you like the mandalorian
mandalorian would be with lone wolf and
cub you yeah wolf cup the santuichi
movies if you like samurai movies you
should watch that [ __ ] too okay so
victor says jenny if you read house of
leaves not yet but i'm gonna do it
because
i want to do
a re-read and i know i keep saying this
but
house of leaves
as i mentioned before is one of those
books that it's like it's not just a
book it's like a commitment
you really have to kind of like i've
read it before i loved it
uh it's super creepy and it's just like
i love the whole [ __ ] concept of it
and when i
thought about doing the book review show
that was actually that and drude were
one of the first were the first two
books that i
wanted to do and i haven't done either
one of them yet because i'm like waiting
yeah because they're long and they're
involved so i was kind of like okay well
i'll eventually get around to it i will
eventually get around to it i promise
because i want to like give it the do
that it deserves you know what i'm
saying yeah david uh darkness is my ally
was a [ __ ] great song
uh katsushin
also known as shintaro katsu or okatso
shintaro depending on what language
you're speaking in but the japanese just
call him katsu [ __ ]
and katsushin could [ __ ] sing
he was a [ __ ] party animal a lot of
people don't know that he was
he was into blow and he drank a lot and
the [ __ ] could sing
and he also uh did a bunch of uh cool
songs that i
oh no i got him confused but no he could
sing and um he uh
he was a legend he was kind of like a
japanese sinatra
and uh yeah but that song
he sang a song called darkness as my
ally it's good
he's doing all the [ __ ] singing in
the zatuichi's voice with the japanese
[ __ ] music going in the back yeah
yeah
do you guys want to hear some [ __ ]
badass
samurai he the thing is
is zatuichi was not a samurai he was a
yakuza basically
he was a [ __ ] outlaw
well he was one of those kind of like
yeah you know [ __ ] that like
wandered he was like an outcast and he
wandered from town to town helping out
in whatever way professional gambler
which would make him a yakuza well that
was his cover yeah
well no his cover was to be a masseur
well that too but he was he was he was
yakuza also he's blind he was blind and
he had a [ __ ] blind man's cane and
hidden in it was a [ __ ] straight yes
but he could fight better than anybody
yeah even though he was blind didn't
matter if it was dark or not because
yeah it was because he it was always
dark for him yeah and
he's a nice guy
and kind of a loser kind of a fat boy
but uh [ __ ] was a badass with a
sword and he was constantly rising up
constantly rising up to defend
the poor people the downtrodden yeah
yeah defending them against yakuza and
[ __ ]
samurai because samurai were bad too
they were all well everybody was coming
to like [ __ ] with them yeah they're
right you would like how much everybody
was bad and he was always and he was
always uh
uh defending the defending the ladies
i always defended the ladies and he had
a very very soft spot for the [ __ ]
ladies and saving ladies from indenture
and servitude and [ __ ] good i can
trying to get them out of the brothels
because their loser husbands [ __ ]
sold them out to the brothels and [ __ ]
is that dude you know where was that
trying to straighten that [ __ ] out yeah
yeah
maybe we ought to buy all the satwitchy
movies we should we do have all the lone
wolf club movies
but like i said there's only six of
those
not too movies
there were 26 of them and they varied in
quality i liked all of the ones that
i've seen i haven't seen all of them
there's a tv series [ __ ] david
mentioned it too yeah cv series if you
like mandalorian that's it all came from
that
but mandalorian was almost almost a damn
near direct rip off a [ __ ] lone wolf
and cup
it was about a guy well it was inspired
by that yeah there's about again and i
mean i'm pretty sure they've
acknowledged that right yeah they did
it's about a guy who he is
the main samurai's [ __ ] hit man he's
just he's a he's a uh
a samurai
and uh but he'll go out and execute or
assassinate somebody based upon the
orders of the [ __ ]
shogun
all right
and um
eventually
i can't remember exactly what happens i
think they order him to they order him
to kill some people he doesn't want to
do it
and they uh come for him and they kill
his wife
and he grabs his son and they end up
going on a run yeah and then they end up
[ __ ]
being in hell is what they called it
they became demonic spirits they thought
that they were demonic
remember that baby carpenter well they
were like walking down yeah one of them
was called baby cart from him yeah
everybody because they were walking the
path they weren't dead no but they were
walking the path of like the demonic the
demonic people sure because they were
[ __ ] condemned to death and they're
as like fugitives
so they just had to [ __ ] survive so
whoever comes up against them they're
just gonna kill them they were being
attached by all the emperor's [ __ ]
samurai and all their men
and he's got his little boy with him his
boy's in a baby cart and he's got the
baby cart weaponized with blades and
[ __ ] what was the baby's name [ __ ]
it's so awesome yeah yeah and
basically yeah what's that he's like
he's kind of like baby yoda [ __ ] um
the baby's name was um
thank you david that zatuichi box that
is over a hundred dollars here yeah yeah
yeah it was like how much well the
zatuichi one how much was the
was the um the other one the uh the the
lone wall function the wolf was nearly
80 90 bucks and that's only six movies
so i can imagine like the zanta we do
one
if it has all 26 movies yeah 100 is
actually a pretty good deal yeah lone
wolf and cub came in was uh collectors
that was criteria
yeah and it came with [ __ ] impartials
and it opened with little comic books
because it came
that was a comic book movie it started
as a comic book a japanese anime that
they made movies for in the 70s
and it comes with all this [ __ ] cool
illustrations and photographs
and um
trying to remember the name of the
little the little baby uh what was that
kid's name
god damn it
there you go
that was his name but diagonal was
basically that him baby yoda
that kid was [ __ ]
i love that kid yeah
and like i said i'm not all into like
because i know how they have like in the
godzilla and the gamer movies have like
the kenny's
we talked about that on the other show
and guy who played the lone wolf
was katsushin's brother
yeah
the guy who played zatoichi
that's why i kind of like
kind of like the two bleed together
because it's like you know
yeah
shintaro katsu's brother is playing him
and she could and i think katsushin
directed some of the lone wolf and cup
he might have yeah
so there's like a lot of like overlap in
this and they were indie films for japan
they're real good
i mean they're all good like i said
every single one of the zanto eg films
i've watched i've liked i love all the
lone wolf and cobb ones um yeah that
kid's awesome victor said never got
around to season two amanda lawrence
season two is better than season one
you need for me too says brandon tunnel
hates kennedy's i do as well
because well kenny's that's a whole
if you've seen any of the gamer movies
of which there were several
um there's always a kid in there
that is like soup and i and i kind of
feel like it's maybe a little unfair to
like the japanese actor because i feel
like a lot of the
annoyance factor is up to
the english dubbing because whoever
dubbed these kids
it was i'm sure it was probably like an
adult doing like a kid's voice so it's
like this really annoying
over the top i don't know but it's that
and it's just like all the tiny shorts
they used to wear it's like this whole
uh you know it's this whole thing hugo
says uh i know you guys are going to
kill me but i like the last summer i
liked the last samurai too it wasn't a
bad movie a matter of fact there was a a
guy who kind of fit
that character
that tom cruise was playing and i think
he was an american guy it was kind of
based on something that actually did
actually happen i don't even know if i
saw that movie though it's pretty good
yeah
tom cruise
i feel like i saw it but i don't like
remember anything about it
tom cruise in the 1800s joins up
with samurai who are fighting imperial
japan as it's rising they don't want it
to modernize
they want it to stay like it was and uh
he ends up getting killed in this big
battle where a bunch of the the last
samurai got killed in and that actually
did happen in japan
now i don't know if the dude that it's
roughly based on if he died in that
battle
but in the movie he did
because i heard later on that there was
an american guy that was like that
he was hanging out with those samurai
yeah
david june says gamra the friend of all
children sure uh he's really neat he's
full of eternal meat also hugo says
uh
yes
he said we should review kingdom
i'm pretty sure we did though
didn't we review kingdom yeah yeah i
think we did that series this one with
the monsters right right all right that
was one with the the uh
it's like a zombie yeah that's right
yeah i liked that a lot yeah i like that
a lot i think we did review that yeah
but it was a while back yeah
so yeah you guys who liked the last
samurai that was not a bad movie i liked
it
see now i'm like kind of like i don't
know and there was i need to re-watch it
before it was some historical press it
was tom cruise i know and there was it
was one of tom cruise's better movies
and it was uh
there was some historical precedent for
it i mean that kind of
there was a guy like that at that period
i don't know if it went down exactly as
it showed in the movie probably not
um
but no uh and that samurai revolt uh
going against the [ __ ] um
over the name what was the name of that
damn
it was the it was i think it was the the
was the end of the tokugawa period in
the beginning of the something or other
japanese republic
uh i can't remember what the name of
that emperor was still like a man or no
[ __ ]
but no there was a samurai revolt where
the last of samurais got [ __ ]
slaughtered out on a damn battlefield
against the guys with [ __ ] guns
gatling guns and [ __ ] and cannons
um
difficult difficult part of japanese
history
they wanted it to remain the same it
couldn't remain the same
you know
japan was becoming a modern country
but yeah i was gonna say i'm pretty sure
we reviewed
at least season one of kingdom because i
remember watching that and really really
digging it that was like really good i
don't remember if we watched season two
do we watch season two
and also if you like that
david said
uh david you said uh oh just an update
from early in the episode tom cruise is
still alive yes scientologist and
homoerotic actor tom cruise is still
alive sure no more erotic actor yeah
yeah that's it that's a good way of
[ __ ] describing watchtop gun
tom tom tom if you're out there
listening
you're only homoerotic because you're
awesome and the gays like you okay
you're not gay tom you're not gay
oh my god you know time's not good one
of these days todd's not gay john
travolta is totally john travolta's
totally gay tom's not good but
and like i said i'm not judging yeah i
just wish the only reason i'm judging is
because they won't just come out and
admit it
just be who you are man that's the 21st
century i like tom cruise i like tom
cruise though i do not know i'm not a
tom cruise fan
i just like tom cruise and i like some
of his movies i don't know he seems like
a douche but okay but i i mean i've
liked some of his movies too
i've liked some of his movies too
i'm not [ __ ] on him like across the
board i like magnolia i liked interview
with the vampire i liked some of the uh
[ __ ] what's this movies though like
the mission impossible movie so they're
pretty good tom cruise is the kind of
actor where he can go into a movie and
play himself and and and but
and you go to see a tom cruise movie
because the thing about it is that if
you're an actor
i kind of feel like if you're an actor
i don't want to see a movie with your
dumb ass in it i want you
to disappear
into the role that you're playing cause
you're an actor
if you're just playing yourself every
time
you're looking it's not really the same
thing it's not the same thing you're
looking at the movie as if it is a high
art form it is not a height or a phone
i'm not saying that i don't say that it
is just entertainment
it's like when you go to see a cigar
movie you go to see steven seagal's fat
ass you know exactly what it is you're
[ __ ] although to be honest with you i
don't really sit through steven seagal
but i will watch like youtube videos
making fun of those movies but i'm not
going to sit through the whole thing i
have like better things to do with an
hour and a half of my life
the problem with the newer stephen
seagal movies is that they're boring
yes
that's the problem
they're just boring
yeah now they are and you can laugh at
him but i'd rather see like people
roasting him on youtube and edit it up
yeah it's much funnier
right but anything after the 90s no you
don't want to watch that under siege one
under siege two pretty good even that
was kind of boring i liked center stage
too i thought it was entertaining it was
funny the first one was okay but
kind of like boring hard to kill um
he had some good ones he had some goods
for the time
and that's when you go to see a steven
seagal movie that's what you're going to
[ __ ] see out for justice that's
another good it was good
but you're you're going to see that
and steven seagal is not playing a role
well he is playing a role he's always
playing a role but he's playing his fake
ass yeah because i don't even think it's
not who he is i don't even think that
there's a steven seagal no at the core
anymore no no no i'm getting existential
on you [ __ ] right now i'm just saying
that it's like i don't even think
there's a steven seagal
yeah i don't even think there's like you
know how like there's a little popcorn
kernel and like i don't even think
there's that [ __ ] this [ __ ] i think that
everything
is
yeah opposed nowadays and it's gotten so
far in that direction
that i don't even think there's a real
person at the bottom of it anymore there
is it's just that's not what you're
seeing on the screen well yeah but well
like i said that's you're not seeing any
of it you're not seeing any of it when i
watch a steve a classic steven seagal
flick i'm sitting there watching the
flick
thinking about him and asian experience
in a swimming pool every time i see
about him then i think about thinking
about him on saturday night live bombing
and i'm thinking about [ __ ] people
talking [ __ ] about him it's thinking
about his [ __ ]
martial arts skill i'm thinking about
[ __ ] all that it's all culminating
into a steven seagal experience okay
it's it's not it's an experience it's an
experience
[Laughter]
well tom cruise is like that but it's in
a slightly different direction okay it's
it but it's a long that's along the same
spectrum though it's similar
it is very similar but tom cruise can
act a bit
okay yeah because like i said i've seen
him in movies where i was like hey i
actually like believed him as that so
you know good job there to me
his [ __ ] his rand some people are
gonna [ __ ] roast me for this i don't
give a [ __ ]
his rendition of lestat i thought i
thought was [ __ ] great no i will give
him that because when i
first heard much like anne rice
when i first heard that he was going to
play lestat i was like oh [ __ ] no [ __ ]
no i thought he was great this stuff but
when we saw the movies much like in rice
i'm like
i didn't love it i would have rather
somebody else but i'm like all right
i'll allow it i'll allow it it was all
right it was all right i can watch i can
watch the interview with the family that
wasn't who i pictured
no but
at all in the books he's supposed to be
16.
he was 16 when he turned into a vampire
yeah that's problematic but so he does
not look 16 yeah okay 16 was in your
prime in the 1500s when he got turned
yeah okay
so
but no i think he did a great lestat
and he did actually he surprised me and
and it would have been so much better if
if if um
if [ __ ] queen of the damned or
they should they should have done queen
of the damn they should have actually
done the second book what was the
[ __ ] well the second was
the vampire lestat they should have done
i really wish they had done the whole
trilogy
as
it was instead of just doing queen of
the damned we're gonna like cram these
two huge novels together right into one
movie terrible that sucks although queen
of the damn it wasn't that bad the
soundtrack was great the soundtrack was
great yeah but but i would have loved to
[ __ ]
not a great idea
younger tom cruise in it would have been
great
if it had the script been good
all right
i could have
i could i could come up with a great
outline of a script like that you could
write that [ __ ] up it would be [ __ ]
great well yeah i'm sure i could have
come up with something better than what
yeah we got and it's almost saying
interview with a vampire
was actually i was not expecting because
i had read the books i loved the [ __ ]
books when i was growing up so when i
saw the movie i was kind of like
i really am not about this right now but
when i saw the movie i'm like you know
what
that was actually way better than i was
expecting so i gave it that but
they didn't do
the [ __ ] trilogy they didn't do the
trilogy they didn't do and interviewed
the vampire they showed it in a vampire
with stat and then with the whole rock
star thing and then they should have
done queen of the damned which is like a
whole different story like why are they
trying to like the interview of the
vampire movie
captured the south very well
the old south and then the new south
when he was
when he was in in louise in new orleans
remembering to run around new orleans
yeah i know um some of those places i
knew where they were and it was just it
was just in that time in the goth scene
was going on at that time in the area
you know it was just it was just a good
time
it was just the way it was back then i
mean tammy said uh he was supposed to be
over six feet had lush fair not
lush hair tiny
not
not tiny with stringy hair hated crews
in that role i honestly
i didn't um i still don't think he was
the best person
for playing vampire lestat i wish they
would have got somebody else
but
the fact that they got him for that
movie i thought i was gonna hate it and
i didn't hate it as much as i thought i
would and i actually ended up liking
that movie but
i still wish they would have got
somebody else to playlist on i still
wish that
it would have been a whole different and
i wish they would have done the whole
trilogy at the time i can't i'm gonna
have to disagree with you guys though
just just going to because what works in
a book
doesn't work well i know that but
and
at that place in time
i thought i think tom cruise was the
best selection for lestat he first of
all he had to be a star
whoever's playing that had to be a star
at that time
and at that time that would have been
the guy to go to there was nobody else
in hollywood that really could have
pulled that off he didn't have to be six
feet tall he didn't have to [ __ ] be
he didn't have to be 16 years old either
you know what i mean that he came across
as a [ __ ]
good vampire yeah he did better than i
was expecting came across was a very
good video he did better than i was so i
was like okay so that's the start and
then and and the and [ __ ] and i'll
tell you what
oh what's his name as louis that was his
best [ __ ] pit brad pitt as louise
that was brad pitt's best work he was
actually great in there and that was he
was great and that was ontario antonio
banderas's best work yeah antonio
banderas did a great job on that
that movie has a lot of feel to it and
visually it's very good the scores gr is
great you can go back and watch that
movie and it holds up
is it 100 like the book no no but what
there were certain things in the book
that just couldn't work in a movie well
the thing about it was that a lot of
things had to change
um the the ages in which they were
turned to a vampire you you yeah that
was a big deal because honestly um you
know claudia in the book was what six
yeah
she was six yeah kristen dunst and she
was a cute little kristen minnie kristen
that would have been [ __ ] up to show
acting like an adult because she was
like 40 or 50 when but she's like a
little girl never yeah
which like i said the books kind of
[ __ ] up you're right and she was six
years old when she was turned she was
six right but she lived to like 50 i
think yeah right yeah yeah so there was
that whole thing too which like i said
you can't really put that in a movie
everyone would like
you're right
you can't show a six-year-old acting
like
an adult because that would be
i messed up i think she was actually
about 10 when they were feeling wasn't
kristin about 10. she was i think she
was 12 but okay or maybe older how old
was kristen dunst when they were filming
that movie i can't remember now but in
the book she was six in case you guys
didn't uh read the book yeah she was six
years old
so um yeah so i that would be
problematic i get why they changed that
um that would be [ __ ] up to show you
no need for me to [ __ ] he nailed it
tom cruise tom cruise had the presence
and the ego of lestat and that's what he
had
that's that's what i think that's why i
kind of like softened on a little bit
because when i first kind of heard about
it because i was super into the books
when i was growing up
and
when they were making much like anne
rice
uh when they were making it into a movie
and she was like oh what you're tom
cruise is playing with snap [ __ ] that um
i kind of felt the same way i was like
what that's not what i was imagining
she imagined i think when she was
writing the character she was imagining
um rutger hauer like in his younger days
which
i would have liked to see that i would
have liked to see rutger hauer like his
hitcher type character but maybe earlier
like that kind of [ __ ]
i kind of because he has tom cruise to
me is not menacing
rucker hower is sexy but also menacing
you know what i mean yeah but then a 16
year old boy wouldn't have been menacing
either up there on skate on the screen
yeah but the whole thing about lestat
was that
he was kind of like still menacing
though because he could still like kill
you so i kind of feel like you had to
bring something like that to the role so
she was picturing when she was writing
it
she was picturing wrecker hauer
that's what she said and i kind of like
feel like maybe somebody more like that
because rucker hower if you see him the
hitcher from 1986
was actually like super and he was in um
you know [ __ ] uh blade runner as well
um i kind of feel like he was
sexy but also
dangerous and i kind of feel like i
don't get dangerous from tom cruise
you know because it's just opinion i
don't get that from tom cruise he just
seems like
a weenie
or
some sort of like not a weenie
necessarily but like um he's just like
overly
cocky like overly confident he seems
like a frat boy to me he seems like a
frat boy and that's why i think i didn't
like it
well
i'm just just going to disagree a little
bit i mean he did
he was very arrogant and i i yeah and
but the thing is is that made it cool to
stop i think this stop would have been
real arrogant
he was
fun and that that that's about what
you're talking about and no he wasn't
this [ __ ] little wafey goth boy he
was well neither was rucker howard right
it's just rucker hauer is bigger than
tom cruise
yeah but at that time rucker howard was
a lot older than tom cruise
but i would have bought that i feel like
i would have bought that more i wouldn't
the movie wouldn't have sold as well i'm
just gonna go with tom cruise tom cruise
i i'm sorry people i mean i thought tom
cruise did a great job in that movie
[ __ ] i think i
for me and i've read both the [ __ ]
books and watched the movie
there's a difference between of the the
book
the stock and the movieless dot yeah the
movieless status tom cruise
tom cruise was was doing a good job he
he he was just like an arrogant [ __ ]
kind of like a mozart type
dude he did have
a lot of [ __ ] vampiric powers and uh
he was just real manipulative and um
a dick and and and [ __ ] lestat was a
dick he was he was a dick but you but he
liked him and and that's kind of the way
tom cruise yeah he a likable dick yeah
tom cruises i don't like him but i know
but i like him he
you know he's competent
uh he's a competent actor he's actually
a competent dude he he's
he can shoot he can fly aircraft uh
he
he tried to better himself you know i
mean he's really kind of came from
nothing um
i think had tom cruise not been a
scientologist
i don't think people his public i think
his public image would have been better
i think people wouldn't have looked at
him
as
sideways as they do he's
especially here's the thing
tom cruise would go on talk shows
and and kind of come off as like a crazy
person sure but you have to understand
the industry they went in there and
instructed him to do certain things the
one to help scientology
to to [ __ ] help and it's very
difficult to defend what it was
yeah institutions as you want to call
them that he was trying to defend but
everybody else is doing the same thing
it's just other institutions there are
other institutions that you might
approve of but they're still all doing
that same yeah but if you can still act
like a normal [ __ ] person then
everybody's gonna like [ __ ] relate to
you more than like somebody that's like
acting like tom cruise at that time okay
first of all what we're talking about
here's another thing we have to consider
what we're talking about is the 2000s
at that time
none of those [ __ ] acted like
[ __ ] people to me very few of them
they're just corporate shills
and he was not shilling for normal
corporations he was shilling for
scientology and it came off kind of
crazy yeah big time to the normal
zeitgeist but me i kind of knew what it
was even though i didn't understand what
scientology was i just knew a chill when
i saw it but that's their jobs actors
jobs are to shill they're all shills
but like i said you know they're just
trying to sell their latest thing which
is fine yeah but like i said just trying
to be like a normal ass person i feel
like tom cruise well he was never a
normal person right he never and you
know it's not entirely his fault no um
you know he never maybe had that
opportunity to be like a normal ass
person because he never was
but
he just like really comes across like
that so i kind of feel like if he hadn't
been a scientologist maybe people would
be more
and i'm not saying like people aren't
[ __ ] you know um you know sympathetic
toward them because they are
but
when he acts weird everybody's gonna
like bring up that scientology thing
because that shit's [ __ ] weird well
that was weird that was weird for the
[ __ ] early
2000s nowhere near as weird as the weird
[ __ ] there sh that other people are
chilling for now on [ __ ] twitter i
mean they're just [ __ ] shills and
they shill for the weirdest [ __ ] [ __ ]
so it's just that you're remembering it
that way
in the context of the time and when we
were there
but the weirdness has escalated so much
in recent years i mean that's really
nothing compared to what's going on now
he's
the deal with tom
is that tom came from nothing
okay nothing
he
they say he was dyslexic
i'm thinking that's a cover story i'm
thinking illiterate is what it was yeah
i'm kind of leading
um he goes into hollywood he's
intelligent he they said he could
memorize
his lines from a script
somebody could read it to him and he
could memorize he's not done but he
couldn't read all right because he came
from nothing
he goes to scientology becomes a
scientologist for his street cred
scientology was predatory
well they saw a vulnerability and they
like [ __ ] exploited it just like
cults do
they
cured his dyslexia
which i'm interpreting that as they
taught him how to read yeah that's
probably okay
that's probably what it really was
and then he became a mega star and
[ __ ] and that church helped him
here's the thing
that church helped tom cruise it
wouldn't help you become a star yeah
without that no well uh yeah yeah yeah i
think he would yeah he would have i
don't think he needed that no he didn't
but it helped him in other ways i think
self-confidence wise and i think um they
focused on his weaknesses and helped him
strengthen where he was weak yeah and
then uh they helped him as
helped him develop his personality
helped him develop confidence
gave him some skill and some philosophy
and some motivation but here's the thing
they did that for tom cruise
church into scientology wouldn't do that
for you they would [ __ ] enslave you
he is
uh tom cruise did not get the normal
scientology experience of course not he
got he got pampered in scientology and i
think they did help him but they didn't
help they wouldn't help
you no as an old person no um they just
wanted somebody that would go out there
and shield for that front for them yeah
sure that's all it was
but um
which like in a way he was used just
like anyone else was from that [ __ ] yeah
but he's also kind of predatory in
scientology he is also he's the number
two man i believe kind of a two it's you
know it's like a two-sided
coin type of situation i feel bad for
him in a
small measure
but in a lot of ways
he's an adult and he should know better
you know what i mean uh so i can't feel
that bad
i can't feel that bad he's the number
two man in scientology yeah and he hangs
out with that [ __ ] douchebag
yeah he's very cabbage he hangs out with
that douche bag yeah
so he didn't get that he did not get the
the average scientology experience no
he's not getting he's not getting locked
in the hole if he does something bad
he's not getting he's not
you know he's not running out of toilet
paper he's not like [ __ ] he's not
enduring the same [ __ ] that like
scientologists on the ground are like
indoors no they're not even bilking him
for much money i don't think they were
building a whole basis so he and [ __ ]
nicole kidman could go forward when they
were married
when they were married
so um
now it's time it's tom cruise a
scientologist you're [ __ ] right that
dude's a scientologist it's so sad
though yeah it kind of like makes me sad
but well it worked for him
now does he believe that he can [ __ ]
control space-time continuum maybe
i kind of feel like maybe he does
believe it
maybe i think he does believe that it's
a religious faith you know
and if you guys don't well he hasn't
really seen any evidence to the contract
right it's not like he has to live in
the normal world like us you know random
[ __ ]
um he kind of lives in like some
rarified air man it's like he's
you know whatever he wants happens
so
i can see how
living like that in this bubble where
you don't really have to like deal with
regular people's problems
um
i can see how you could think that maybe
you had some [ __ ] superpowers i could
see that and some and a lot of his
movies are [ __ ] great
oblivion i liked it
[ __ ] uh remember that one oblivia
yeah and like i said i'm not [ __ ] on
him like just across the board i like
some of his movies okay i liked him in
interview with the vampire grudgingly
fallout series i got off they're good
you know or uh you know i liked a lot of
the mission impossible i'm gonna be i'm
gonna be a [ __ ] contrary [ __ ]
and buy the mummy
not just for tom cruise that was one of
many reasons i didn't like it but
the fact that he was in it didn't help
um but he wasn't the main reason why i
didn't like it but um you know so i'm
not like just just just [ __ ] on tom
cruise just like you know
unilaterally i'm just kind of like
i don't know
i kind of wish
i wish
that he would [ __ ] wake up
and get out of the [ __ ] and be a normal
person like the rest of us
but
good night darn i don't know i just
don't think it's gonna happen and that
like it makes me sad it makes me sad but
like i said i kind of feel like once
you're that far into the [ __ ] what's the
matter pope
once you're that far into the [ __ ]
and
you have so much money
and so many people
crawling up your ass
24 7
that you don't really have to like deal
with normal people [ __ ] ever
that must be really weird absolutely i
don't know i i've never experienced that
so i don't really know stop it poop
but
scott says who cares if tom cruise is
normal like anyone is yeah but
the thing about it though is that
there's there's normal
there's no says to think it's normal but
there's also another level of not normal
where people don't have to like deal
with
anything that quote unquote regular
people have to deal with now no need for
me too says [ __ ] i'm sorry in this
movie i think tom is correct he says now
i'm with you tom as a book reader i love
the movie
the movie the stuff no it was good it
wasn't like i don't think it was the
best possible movie that could be made
for that book but i think it was like
the best
adaptation at the time that could have
come out but i do kind of wish
and maybe eventually somebody will do
this i do kind of wish that they had
made like the whole trilogy
with
you know more
uh faithfulness to
the way that it actually was although
like i said tom cruise actually
surprised me i wasn't pissed off about
the other victims the victor says tom
cruise mom was a special ed teacher he
probably had dyslexia and wasn't
illiterate maybe
but you dude you never can't tell i mean
some some
some of the people i've known that were
illiterate had parents that could read
and write they just
the kid couldn't read and write
doesn't mean anything terry says jenny
what was the better
the tom cruise mommy or the film the
pyramid i didn't see the pyramid i don't
think i did either did the pyramid have
tom cruise in it did it i don't know why
why are we comparing that i didn't love
the mummy i'm just i didn't hate it
but
i just it just it made me mad because i
love the universal
uh monster so much and i love boris
karlaf i love like all that old [ __ ] and
i just kind of like wish that they
hadn't
like if you're gonna make a movie like
that just make its own thing like do its
own thing like don't try to associate it
with hey it's like we're doing a reboot
of the universal monsters and here's
this action movie that has nothing to do
with like the [ __ ] original mummy
movie like don't do that jess pepper
says [ __ ]
tom cruise just won't come out of the
closet
[ __ ] poor top
top uh every scientologist that knows
tom and [ __ ]
uh
they've asked him [ __ ] this is like
ex-scientologist
who will talk [ __ ] they'll tell the
truth about anybody they've been asked
is tom cruise gay and they'll say no
he's not
is it he is straight i don't think tom
cruise is but i'm not okay for sure john
travel [ __ ] for sure
john travolta's gay
i don't know if you guys know this but i
might have mentioned this on one of my
lashes
uh john travolta
had a uh house in port orange which was
a little bit south of where i grew up
my aunt whose name is pat
she had a she ran a salon
in port orange and john travolta was one
of her clients
so john travolta would come in sometimes
to get his hair done or get like [ __ ]
facials or whatever
and her and everybody in that [ __ ]
salon knew that that [ __ ] was gay yeah
but and she told me that what i got
pictures of him kissing dudes you know
and she's like i don't understand like
why he doesn't just tell him but it's
like you know it's the 21st century like
no one cares anymore well so it's kind
of like i don't understand like we he
won't just very retro but scientology
well the thing about it is scientology
is very very very very anti-gay
yeah so they're kind of like uh if
you're gay that means something doesn't
matter with you you need more auditing
blah blah blah they have this whole
thing so he can't i kind of feel like
he's at the age now where he can't come
out because it'll be like a repudiation
of everything that he's
said and done up to this time another
part of right if he comes out
scientology will [ __ ] dump all the
files they have on him well that too
during your auditing yeah it says some
blackmail [ __ ] thing yeah during your
auditing which is like your confessions
during your inquisition
they record everything you say about
your sins they don't call them this but
it's what it is they record all your
sins well yeah there's these things
if you leave the church or speak out
against the church they dump all your
files to the public
that's why
that's why he hasn't left the church and
that's why he hasn't gone he hasn't come
out if he comes out they'll go yeah that
[ __ ] he's although i kind of
feel like nowadays like everybody like
if everybody cares what the church right
if like if somebody came out and said oh
john travolta's gay a bit like yeah and
but the thing is that the church would
come out and say well he's gay because
he had sex with a dog when he was five
they would say some i feel like even
nowadays no one would no one no one
would buy that i believe it but two even
if they did no one would care right now
here's the thing about tom
tom cruise isn't going to leave the
church
um yeah they got dirt on him i'm sure
they do
but it's probably not really that much
of a big deal um he's not gonna leave
because he loves the church
they treat him pretty well he doesn't
get the worst he has he has like little
vacations where he like vanishes from
the church evidently these are
high-ranking church members that i
[ __ ] got this from by [ __ ] well we
had angry gay pope on here and he's
connected with [ __ ] uh some like the
number twos and threes and fours to that
church
well a lot of the higher-ups have left
yeah they've all left and they're all
talking
so and you know we've
like i said we've done shows with them
and [ __ ] they do their own shows and
you can hear what they say
cruz doesn't leave because he's
satisfied with the church all right
um well it works for him yeah it works
for him he's having a good time and he
obviously doesn't care if it works for
anyone else no he didn't care no well
they do [ __ ] for him they'll build him a
car or a motorcycle so the fact that
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] if they're
like abusing hundreds thousands of
people it's like well i get a motorcycle
in a cool apartment so what the [ __ ]
should i care yeah well which again
makes me hate him even more
i kind of understand it though
because you could say the same thing for
the army in the navy
it is a like a military system all right
the problem is you have children in it
and you have people that were bored into
it which is not the same as the military
it's not as involved because yeah
you were like born into it yeah in the
military you volunteered
um you have people that are in a
paramilitary system and it is
paramilitary it's based after the navy
you're in a paramilitary system and you
were born into it
you didn't choose it you were born into
it that's not good
okay
it's not the same as volunteering
so
tom cruise is rationals like oh yeah of
course you got washouts and people
dropping out and failing they [ __ ]
suck
well yeah he's gonna blame them yeah
that's what you would do that's what
people do well well that's what you
would do in the middle that's how you
make yourself feel better no that's how
you justify oh no
you're looking at it from a civilian
point of view and a military point of
view they volunteered and they [ __ ]
failed and they washed out
okay they [ __ ] sucked
but the problem is is that with the
church of scientology the people that
are [ __ ] being punished and watching
out didn't volunteer for it
right born into it or something like
that you're born into it you don't
really have a lot of you really it's not
like they're they enslave you from when
you're a [ __ ] child that's right so
it's not quite it's not quite the same
but there's read seriously there's a
religious
justifications for all this though read
beyond belief yeah by jenna miscavige
yeah yeah it is a horrifying horrifying
book but it's like really really good i
got notifications
with military style
indoctrination and training that that
that scientology does i got no problem
with that
the problem is is that these are not
volunteers
exactly
like i said if you want to join that
[ __ ] into it right you want to be that
way all right i don't get it but okay
yeah it's not quite the same okay and
you're forced into it that's it's like
they're being drafted by their parents i
don't believe in a draft
okay
well yeah no one should be made to do
that kind of [ __ ] against their will
yeah like i said you're not if you raise
a kid in the church that's right really
that's like scientology is going to say
well this is an emergency situation
we're trying to save the earth they're
drafted
they must do this
man that's not the thing is they're in
an imaginary world where they're trying
to clear the planet
and they're gonna clear the planet at
forty thousand dollars a pop no not
gonna happen the average person doesn't
have forty thousand dollars to [ __ ]
get clear and i wish i had four imagine
yeah it's just [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] that
they're doing i do know but
tom's probably doesn't give a [ __ ] about
that he's like ah yeah well like i said
it's not his problem it's not his
problems other people's problems
but a bajillion dollars
um he doesn't have to do
any of the punishments he can go to all
those little scientology bases and
they'll kiss his ass kiss his ass you
guys rooms and [ __ ] so why should he
care
why should he care he's very he doesn't
really give a [ __ ] about anybody like on
the ground
no so what his his
his rationale will be
these people are doing their religious
duties i know i know that's what his
rationale would be
i know he does yeah but that doesn't
matter it's still shitty
you're still a shitty person most people
are like that in the world though yeah
well you're still a shitty person most
people are [ __ ] before you're so shitty
well yeah you think i don't know that
holy crap you have people and all these
other civilizations all over [ __ ]
thinking something you're still a shitty
person yeah sorry you're still a shitty
person
um you know
sorry you're still a shitty person
so here no i know he doesn't care he
would look at you and go well who are
you
well yeah like who are you
you're not even clear well that's why i
don't give a [ __ ] like you got deaton's
on you that's why i don't give a [ __ ]
about him either and i will [ __ ] on his
stupid [ __ ] movies because
he wouldn't give a [ __ ] about me
i'm just some nobody
he's tom [ __ ] chris you got [ __ ]
themes on you right you're [ __ ] you
got space cooties yeah sure yeah you got
a space goose
whatever time
you're a [ __ ] but they believe that i
know they do i know so
uh pat says but we'll see that's the
reason why he pisses me off that's the
reason why i'm flexible i i guess
because i was well you're morally
flexible and you're like you're willing
to like give a pass to people like that
um i'm not so you know i think it has
something to do with me
i'm not giving a pass to people i think
i had something i think it had a lot to
do with me growing up in other countries
and other cultures at the time
where you know me growing up in brazil
people have beliefs
and the beliefs are not true but they
believe them
and they have no excuse sorry
nothing is an excuse no excuse no excuse
okay i'm just gonna move on i'm not
giving you an excuse you could always
flip that around and say well that's
bigotry
i'm sorry if you believe stupid things
yeah people stupid [ __ ] like you believe
stupid things i'm sorry that's not an
excuse i'm not gonna kill you or nothing
i just it's not an excuse
uh pat says how did leah remini escape
from scientology honestly leah remini
well she was a celebrity one you should
watch the series it's really yeah it's
really good really good um you know and
i you know
all the props like getting her out of
that [ __ ] like she was you know she was
raised in it her parents were
scientologists
so she grew up with it
so the fact that she like
kind of came to her senses and was like
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] and got out
of there like it was easier for her i
will give her that because she had a lot
of money and she was very famous
um so obviously it was a lot easier for
her than it would have been for like
people on the ground
but the fact that she was willing to use
that i admired that she was willing to
use her fame
to
you know put her money behind that her
reputation behind i'm gonna make this
whole series and we're gonna like
try to get people out of this [ __ ]
which like i said that's probably the
best use of her spooky's asking to go
outside
okay well don't you go far okay put her
little clothes on
i mean the fact that she used her uh her
fame and her notoriety and her money and
she actually like put that behind
you know making several seasons of a
series that it's like you know they
wanted to expose it they wanted to like
help people get out of there um
you know you you have to like admire
that like i said it was probably easier
for her to get out she wasn't um because
there's
there's two different like
tears i guess in scientology you have
like your [ __ ]
people that are in the [ __ ] they live
in the dorms or whatever and they just
like work for them and then you have
like your public scientologists which is
like normal people
but these are usually like
wealthier people and they're in
scientology but they don't have to like
live in the [ __ ] they don't have to like
work for the cult they don't have to do
all that they can have like a relatively
normal life and a lot of celebrities are
in that tier and she was in that tear
but she kind of got to a point where
she's like i think it was after um
shelley miscavige disappeared
um and no one knows entirely where she's
at at this point
they kind of know where she's at but
they didn't really know but the fact
that like she just went to an event and
was like hey where's shelley because she
was a friend of hers
and everybody like jumped her [ __ ] about
it and she was like yeah [ __ ] this i
don't i don't like how this is going
because she'd been like questioning it
for a long time so she um got out but
like i said people that
are just
sort of on the ground i guess and like
aren't rich and aren't famous and stuff
a lot of them have to do
have to do like some [ __ ] where they
just like hide in a car and like [ __ ]
drive out it's just like it's like a
mormon thing where you kind of like
escape from the cult and like they'll
come after you and
it's that kind of [ __ ] but celebrities
have it a lot easier because like i said
they have money but
i will say like i said i give her a lot
of prompts because
she at least used her
celebrity and used her money to
kind of try to like take them down and
try to like get people out of there
which
you know that's really admirable that's
like really what what i would have done
in the same situation i guess but if
you're like kind of a lower down
scientologist
you don't really have the same
resources
so you know so i admire that she did
that and she's like trying to get people
out of there or at least trying to get
more people not to
fall for it or not to get into it you
know what i mean so you know you have
you have to give her like that much
[Music]
pat said
it's just that i thought if you left
scientology
uh miscavige and his group would get you
and they wouldn't be alive long
that only applies to
the really higher up more public
people
if you're just some lower down it's just
like life in general if you're some like
lower down
schlub that no one cares about they're
not going to give a [ __ ] about you but
if you're kind of like a higher up
um they will actually because some of
the higher ups that have escaped that
have like shows and stuff
they will
i don't know if they have you killed so
much nowadays they used to
uh and they'll make it look like a
suicide they'll do all that kind of [ __ ]
but nowadays i kind of feel like they're
more
we're gonna like put up a website saying
this person is a pedophile type of [ __ ]
yeah they're they do that kind of [ __ ]
and i'm not sure they actually ever
killed anybody directly they usually did
things maybe back in the day i think
back in the day well there were not a
lot they would harass there was a couple
cases that were questionable yeah you're
not sure but i think what they were
doing is harassing people and putting so
much pressure on them they killed
themselves
that seemed to be a lot of or they would
take drugs and over d them od themselves
you know it's that kind of book which
can't blame most like [ __ ]
scientologists i don't
[ __ ] i don't think there's any
evidence of them actually going out and
say like shooting somebody in the back
of the head well there was a case in
it was in either france or germany it
wasn't like a while back but i remember
like some dude suspiciously
dying in a super like boiling hot
water like bathtub
and um i remember there was some
question over like whether he killed
himself or whether it was murder
but there were scientologists involved i
actually worked at the company
where um
lisa mcpherson worked she's you guys
yeah if you guys look up the case of
lisa mcpherson
um on wikipedia
i worked at the same like she had been
dead for many years but i worked at the
same company with a lot of people that
knew her and i worked with her
roommate who was her roommate at the
time and
a lot of them had to testify at her
wrongful death trial
and they're still not really sure
what the [ __ ] happened with that because
apparently she had a psychotic episode
she's running down the street naked
um
and like kind of she either got hit by a
car like she's like being threatened to
be hit by a car or whatever and it's
like she was acting like crazy so they
put her in this thing
and then the scientologists
came to the hospital and got her
and then they're like oh we'll take care
of this because you know we take care of
our own or whatever and they took her
back to the fort harrison hotel in
clearwater
and she was in there for like a really
long time and she essentially
starved to death and then when they
found her she was all like covered with
like [ __ ] bug bites she'd been eaten
by roaches partially yeah
so
um and i worked with a lot of the
[ __ ] that testified at that
trial
um saying oh we didn't know we didn't do
any of that stuff and honestly i worked
for those people and i don't buy it
don't buy it i kind of feel like a lot
of those people
just kind of let her die
they let her die
because they really really believe they
had something called purification run
down yeah that's what it's called yeah
during purification run down she's not
really giving you all the details
there's a system for what they do no i
know if a person i'm telling them
if a person kind of starts losing their
[ __ ] and going crazy because the
scientologist [ __ ] that they're
doing because what they do to you they
will absolutely make you crazy
but then they like pretend that it's
like no i'm not going to get you
finished
i'm not going to let you visit yes
i worked with these [ __ ] i know
i'm telling them what a purification
rundown is okay i'm just saying you
start acting crazy what they'll do is
they'll grab you
um if they start if they think you're
having a psychotic break
and they'll put you in a cell and the
policy is is that they won't talk to you
because they think that will clear your
insanity
but actually what it usually ends up
happening is is that it gets worse
well obviously as it gets worse they
give them all kinds of [ __ ] stupid
ass instructions on how to deal with a
person who's had a psychotic break
they won't call a [ __ ] psychologist
or a hospital or anything well of course
because that would be proof that
scientology doesn't work yep uh they're
gonna try to fix it themselves so they
had her in a cell
and it was hot there's no air
conditioning it wasn't was it called big
blue wasn't that in big blue where was
it it was in clear water clear water it
was in the fort harrison fort harrison
right yep they a lot of times to say
right near where i used to work to save
money the scientology abilities [ __ ]
they'll buy these huge ass buildings
well fort harrison was there but they
took it over it wasn't a hotel anymore
so they bought it they'll buy these big
ass [ __ ] buildings and to save money
they won't buy any toilet paper or have
any ac in parts of it
so they'll be holding people in these
cells
for purification run down without the ac
it was hot as [ __ ]
there's like you just need some vitamins
yeah and you need vitamins and no one to
talk to you right and they were given
they evidently weren't giving her enough
water
nope and she dehydrated and died and the
roaches ate her they had roaches in
there because because it's florida it's
florida and they weren't [ __ ]
bothering to spend money on [ __ ]
regular poisoning and decontamination
well if she just pulled that in herself
she pulled that yeah and that's how they
would do they would say well her bad
thinking made all this happen yep that
she pulled this in herself that's what
they that so that's how they think it's
like bad cop they're
monsters their mother pulling it in
yourself is almost kind of like an
indian thing of karma that's what
they're talking about well she's
thinking a certain way and acting a
certain way so bad things happen to you
so you deserve what happens basically
you get you reach honestly
it's just kind of like it's no different
than like remember that [ __ ] that went
around the night is like the secret and
all that kind of [ __ ]
i kind of feel like that's people
that don't understand that life is
random and bad [ __ ] happens to good
people so they're trying to like stave
off bad [ __ ] happening to them by saying
oh i'm a good person
and i'm putting good energy out into the
universe therefore nothing bad can
happen to me guess what bad [ __ ] can
happen to everybody because it's [ __ ]
random so it's like please [ __ ] deal
with that don't make this a whole thing
because scientology has made a like a
whole [ __ ] thing of it
where
if you're like a good scientologist
you're a good person you're putting all
this stuff like nothing bad will happen
to you that is [ __ ] that is not how
the world works please
please don't be that way because i kind
of feel like also
it kind of gives you this thing to [ __ ]
on people who bad things happen to you
because you'll oh well you must have
done something bad because you must have
done something to deserve that
not everybody did
i hate to break it to you bad [ __ ]
happens to everybody
at one time or another and it doesn't
mean that you did anything to deserve
that it just means that [ __ ] is random
and sometimes bad [ __ ] happens to you so
the fact that they have codified this
monstrous
morality is like really
uh
it just it makes me so so angry that
makes me so angry well one of the weird
things about it
she called it a monstrous morality
one of the weird things about it is that
it's not as monstrous as you think it
was
they kind of picked a bunch of little
things from a bunch of other religions
and philosophies and put them together
it wasn't the intent that it was
monstrous on most of it
well it never is is it nobody intends to
be monstrous
lrh
thought that that was true
and then over time and other people
implementing it you can pervert anything
uh and when when you try to take
something that's basically
a kind of a spiritual
occult system similar to something like
out of aleister crawley you take that
and try to
make it a corporate system or religious
system
that has a bunch of people trying to
implement it like a law
man it [ __ ] goes wrong
it doesn't really [ __ ] work
no and and really all religions are are
like this
which is why i don't if you do
i'm not down with any of them that's why
if you do that too to christianity if
you try to implement it that way you end
up with the catholic church and and and
the things that the catholic church was
doing in the 16th and the 1700s is
[ __ ] ridiculous because all of the
because it all comes down to all of them
it all comes down to
victim
blaming that's what it all comes down to
and
the fact that it all comes down to
victim blaming
is because people
don't want to think that the universe is
indifferent to them that is like really
scary
so they want to feel like they have some
control
so it's like oh well bad things happen
to those people so they must have done
something to deserve it i didn't do
anything to deserve it so therefore i'm
fine i kind of feel like that's
the
sort of like little kernel
of all of this [ __ ] well that's that's
you want to feel like you have control
over the universe bad things happen to
those people because they did something
to deserve it i didn't do anything to
serve it i'm fine that's one element
that's not how the world works that's
one element of it there's also there
were also other elements to scientology
well i'm just not i'm not talking about
just scientology i'm just talking about
like religious uh feelings in general
you want to feel like you're special you
want to feel like you're
uh chosen you want to feel like you're
you know bad things aren't going to
happen to you because you have some
control but you don't you don't you're
also under attack by outside forces well
that too that's another thing demons or
thetans or you know the scientology
would say
yeah something outside of you is [ __ ]
with you and that we can so
that way you can fix it or you can blame
your bad actions on outside forces
that's another thing too it's all kind
of like you're everything bad you do is
attributable to an outside force
everything bad that happens to you oh
that must be because someone put a curse
on me or that must be because i wasn't
good enough or that must be
it's all that kind of thing and there's
another layer you can level in on that
yeah you have this thetan or this demon
that's done this to you but you've you
failed to fix it
so now we're gonna fix it and drive this
demon out and you're gonna it's gonna
cost money
so there's a bunch of different things
that they can do
to you in these systems
well yeah but yeah when you get down to
it like i said i kind of feel like it
all comes down to
a couple of different like core
principles
core principles being
no one wants to think that they are a
bad person or they can do bad things for
no reason
um everybody has to if they do something
shitty there's always some outside
reason why they did that it was demons
or it was
thetans it was something so everybody
has to have that so they can like make
themselves come off like the better
person that was an outside force doing
it it wasn't me
so you have that
then you also have this uh you know
thought process of
you know kind of like
if something bad happens that means that
you know the person that the bad thing
happened to
they did something to deserve that
because bad things only happen to people
that deserve it because there's like
some weird karmic
you know christian type of whatever it's
like everybody punishes and it's kind of
like but the world doesn't work like
that like i said the universe is
indifferent so but i feel like people
have a really hard time with that
concept so they really have to
so i feel like those two core concepts
are kind of like
one the root of every religion in the
world two the root of a lot of uh evil
in the world because it's very evil it's
very easy to
take your personal responsibility and
fob it off
on some other like oh that was a demon
that did that oh that was something else
that did that or
something bad happened to that person so
they must have done something to deserve
that and that's not the case that's not
the case
how long have been streaming uh three
hours and 31 minutes it's about time to
[ __ ] shut it down you think oh yeah
we've been streaming for almost four
hours but we got into a really good
discussion now yeah victor says getting
eaten by roaches is bad for you yeah
when i heard about that and seriously go
look at the wikipedia page for lisa
mcpherson
i worked with a her roommate who was our
sales manager at the time that i worked
that i'm not naming it
so i don't get sued i don't think
they're around her
but
i worked with a lot of people that
testified at her
wrongful death trial
and
i don't know i kind of feel like they it
was a really weird to like work around
those people because
they didn't really seem to see
i don't know i kind of feel like they
were true believers in the sense that
well they thought they were helping her
but they clearly were not helping her
you don't lock a person in a room with
no food or water
or anything there was nothing in there
it was just like a mattress
and a bed frame
the these are scientologists
yes
this is why i had to move away from
clear water after eight months because
i'm like i can't [ __ ] deal with that
you're not dealing with a normal thought
process that's why boy i know
they were following scientology they
were ksw they were keeping scientology
working that's what they call it that's
what scientology told them to do and
that's what they did
yeah see i can't i'm sorry i just can't
i can't get down with that i just can't
they believe it it is a scientific
system that works
yeah well good for what the book says
like i'm real like look i'm real like
[ __ ] i give a lot of latitude to
whatever like people's beliefs are but
you get into this [ __ ] where it's like
we take this woman who's clearly like
mentally ill and she's mentally ill
because of the [ __ ] she's been brought
up in because scientology is [ __ ]
crazy
and it's like we're gonna lock her in a
room with no food or water and expect
her to get better yeah and then she gets
eaten by roaches and then they're trying
to like and dies of like essentially
like dehydration and starvation and then
they stand up in a court
and they essentially say well like well
we're not responsible like we don't
[ __ ] like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that what they'll do is they'll say
this is our religious faith right [ __ ]
that i'm sorry
this is what the religion says [ __ ] that
we did what the religion said and um
not having under america i'm not having
it under american law
um
a lot sometimes that works not all the
time but sometimes that works depending
on well i feel the same way look if your
religious beliefs
say you know something harmless
okay fine do whatever you want to do if
your religious beliefs say i'm allowed
to like kill a child because i'm
exercising a demon from them [ __ ] that
murder
that's still murder there's a lot of
weird religious beliefs out there
getting away with a lot of weird [ __ ]
although like i said i kind of feel like
they don't get a lot because even a lot
of the cases because there have been a
few cases like if you're not from the us
but there have been a few cases where
some fundamentalist christians have
tried to
at least like absolve blame from
themselves because like well we thought
the kid was possessed by a demon and so
we accidentally on purpose like
suffocated them
because they were trying to do like some
weird ritual where they're like trying
to get the demon out and there's been
like several cases of that in the last
uh you know 20 years or so
and it's like i kind of feel like okay
to an extent
as i said if your religious beliefs are
harmless
like you just want to like you know
smoke some pot or like you know go on
your [ __ ] spirit walk or whatever
that's fine i don't give a [ __ ] about
that
but you're like [ __ ] smothering
children to death no it was no
yeah but then there was other [ __ ] other
than that that they got away with for a
long time like like children of god
got along god got away with having sex
with children and swapping children yes
you know that's a long long time if it's
illegal it's illegal for everybody yeah
now i think they i think they
had to run to mexico
so they could continue that i'm not sure
we have to go back and look at that one
but children of god [ __ ] did all
kinds of weird [ __ ] sexual [ __ ] they
did it was flirty fishing and what they
called it was pimping out the girls
and
they got away with it and i think it was
decades
they did well like i said it becomes
more problematic they knew that it was
here's the thing
the the courts of the time knew that
that [ __ ] was wrong but the way they're
[ __ ] deciphering what they what what
laws said they're like well
i guess okay we can do that well the
thing about it is taking a long time
well you get into like um kind of a
tangled area when you're talking about
adults like if you're talking about like
people that are in a cult and they're
adults and they're going out and doing
the flirty fishing thing or they're
doing something that
you know is questionable would be
questionable in like normal society
there comes a question of
you know these are adults um are they in
their right mind like were they like
were they acting on their own consent is
it fine
you know it's it's obviously a lot more
clear-cut when you're talking about
children because obviously that shit's
never okay
but when adults are concerned you really
have to kind of look into
how long of these people been in the
cult were they on some kind of drug how
you know were they like manipulated in
some other way like you know through
some other like oh you know what happens
if the cult says oh we're gonna kill
your family if you don't do this you
know what i mean they're not drugged
they're not it looks like they're doing
[ __ ] on their own free will but they're
really not because they're like well
they said they were gonna kill my family
if i don't do this so it's kind of like
it becomes a lot more
thorny when you're dealing with adults
when you're dealing with children
obviously that's a lot more clear-cut
but so that's why cults i think are so
insidious because
a lot of them are dealing with adults
who you would think
know better
and these are people that oh we just
well we joined the cult when i was you
know 24 or something you and you would
think that it's like well they have all
their faculties
but
you really kind of have to like look
into so every case is different wow you
don't know if that person is
all there you don't know if they were
being forced to do something against
their will like in some other way that
you can't see it's like you know you
have to yeah
here's a good one here's a good one to
look at
when you're talking about cults
one of the best cults out there is a
best as in it's a long-lived cult it's
successful
the members are tight
you don't hear much about it anymore
reverend hong song moon from korea
yeah moonies the moneys
the moonies are christians
but it's a korean christian cult
they have a lot of money
they stick to themselves
they are very kind of apocalyptic they
believe in a bunch of occult stuff too
do they recruit people in airports
anymore they used to back in the 70s
i remember that very successful the
members are very loyal to it
the main
complaint about them is that they kind
of have a disconnection policy if
somebody leaves a church you can't talk
to them anymore
so they kind of break up families
um they're real strict about certain
things that they do they're making a lot
of money
it's probably through real estate
business ventures and stuff well like
they're still around
it's a weird cult
um
reverend bishop how about that yeah we
have to write that down yeah
i keep forgetting about them reverend
moon was uh i don't know if he's still
alive or not
uh he's gotta be dead by now right very
charismatic guy
very powerful intelligent
and uh very entertaining the cult liked
him
he would tell [ __ ] stories that would
[ __ ] amaze people you know he talked
about going out of body and [ __ ]
project
astral projection and everything
he claimed to have defeated communism
uh [ __ ] in soviet union he defeated
them
um yeah me too
he did it single-handedly spiritually
yeah he actually projected and defeated
communism and she went back
i also did that told a story i did that
[ __ ] before him yeah i'm a hipster
yeah no one can previously we need to
[ __ ] do the moonies
would be a good idea
that'll be on the next poll so
now there were there were complaints you
know what i mean that you know if you
leave the church you can't talk to your
family they're still in the church you
know what i mean disconnection is what
what they call it in in in scientific
scientology sure and disconnection is
actually the biggest complaint
i kind of feel like look i'm just going
to say right here
if my family were still in were
scientologists and i got the [ __ ] out of
there i don't think i would want to talk
to them anymore they won't they do that
that's you they want to talk to them and
tell them that they're all right
and then the family members that said
they're like you still in there [ __ ] off
bye
that's not true the family members that
stayed do want to talk to their kids
that left like i get that just i know
that i know that's just me the church
won't let them yeah i know all right i
know i know that's shitty that's really
what it is and that's the same with the
moonies somebody leaves the rest of the
family want to talk to that that person
but the church won't let them all right
and another one that does that is the um
jehovah's witness does that well a lot
of cults do that yeah they want to
separate you from a support system right
is what they're trying to do jehovah
witness that's cult 101 juggle witness
the main problem with jehovah's witness
is that they won't report pedos
well yeah but one of the problems
and disconnection is pito is a
disconnect
but the people and and i've uh i
subscribed to j you know like those
youtubers that jenny doesn't want me
talking to
or hanging out with i subscribed to x
[ __ ] um [ __ ] i'm not talking about
those ones you know which one no i
subscribe to them all i listen to
everybody
jenny doesn't like that not everybody
yeah
everybody's just interesting i talk i
[ __ ] subscribe and and interact
um
good i'm not scared of information i
want to hear everything oh i'm scared of
information you're scared of information
i want to hear everything even if it's
subversive
all right
because you know whatever tom yeah
so anyway you you think whatever you
want i am thinking whatever i want to
think yeah obviously mind control me
obviously she's trying to mind control
me i'm not trying to mind control
you just you you just take a look at how
she acts like you just think things that
are untrue but i'm just going to share
your opinion but i think a lot of things
that are untrue in my opinion yeah okay
i'm just going to let you your opinion
i'm just going to let you write i'm just
going to let you write their opinions
all right
yeah victor says he subscribes to all
youtubers right yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know shut up victor you know you know
what i'm feeling look so what was i
talking about i don't know [ __ ] see you
[ __ ] wanna [ __ ] me up oh my goodness
you [ __ ] snap my testosterone level
it's all this damn all this damn
messaging yeah join the club
that's like i try to talk and like you
just like in a room
that's what you do but i do it and you
he gets mad i'm not getting i'm not mad
yeah it's all entertaining yeah you were
yeah all right
so what was i talking about
which cult i don't know i wasn't really
all right [ __ ] it
that wasn't really talking about it
well
earlier you were talking about what you
were talking about disconnection is what
you're talking about disconnection yeah
and you were talking about the jehovah's
witnesses vis-a-vis disconnection yeah
so i was kind of listening and who else
is about uh yeah but i forgot what my
point was
i'm drunk so i can't remember
i was going to i was going to say
something about disconnection and uh the
way cults work but it doesn't matter
well like i said that's kind of like
cult 101 uh they want to separate you
from anyone that
has any um
uh you know
linked to your old life
so they don't want anybody they want you
to be
essentially
reborn
um
it's all [ __ ] though well yeah i
know but i'm just saying that's how
cults operate yeah they want you to be
reborn in their [ __ ] in their belief
system they don't want you to have any
links to like your past
so a lot of them will try to cut you off
from your friends family they don't want
you having like any kind of like normal
life at all they just want you
to be
essentially like i said reborn in this
new identity
um of this cult that you're in now and
you don't have anything to do with your
old [ __ ] like i said
i don't know i kind of feel like if i
was in a situation where
you know if i'd been brought up in
scientology and i was just kind of like
yeah i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
and like my parents wouldn't leave i
kind of feel like i don't know and maybe
this is just me and i'm not [ __ ] on
anybody that wouldn't do this but uh i
kind of feel like in my parents state
i'd just be like chew [ __ ] you i'm out
because if you're gonna stay there that
means you give a [ __ ] more about the
church then you give a [ __ ] about me
your own kid
um so
what would be new i really don't have
any use for you after that point i don't
see what would be new about that i mean
you see that over and over again well
yeah like i'm saying no i'm not yeah
well like i said i'm not that's why i
don't have
i kind of feel like even now it's better
now than it used to be but i kind of
feel like people still have a thing it's
like oh they're my parents it's like who
gives a [ __ ] they're just like some
random people that gave you some dna
okay i love choosing i you know look i
love my mom like my dad's like pretty
awesome and you know whatever but it's
like if they
were in a cult
and i got out of that cult and like they
were like no we're just gonna stay here
we love it i'd just be like all right
[ __ ] you then i'm just like and i would
not be sad about like not talking to
them again i don't think there's
anything please don't feel if your
parents suck please don't feel bad
about not talking to them again that's
not
a failure that's not anything like that
it's just not most parents are just two
people that were [ __ ] and that's a
bunch that's what i mean it's like and
then the kids took the scattering i know
people have this thing it's like oh
family is everything and it's like oh
that's your parents and everybody like
that's cool and it's like
it depends on who your parents are if
your parents blow
then i really don't think you should
feel bad at all
about not talking to them anymore yeah
and i don't feel that way about my
family i'm just saying that i've known
other people that their families were
like holy [ __ ] man like get the [ __ ]
away from that
you have a right people in cults
like you have a right to live your best
life if that's interfering then [ __ ] it
don't think about it don't feel bad
about it
you know seriously don't people in cults
are the kind of people that would choose
the cult over themselves and their
families right that's why they're in
there and like i don't if they if they
weren't that kind of person they
wouldn't be in there yep
so yeah they have children the children
have nothing to do with this cult
they're raised up in this crap now what
the [ __ ] is this and the kids like and
the parents like okay you're out bye
they're not in they weren't in that cult
for you
they were in that cult for themselves
they have nothing to do with you and
yeah and i mean your parents the cults
are selecting that kind of pathology
and like i said i'm you know and i'm not
[ __ ] on everyone's parents i'm just
saying parents they're just people
they're just people you didn't choose if
they weren't your parents you'd see them
as random [ __ ] right
they're
you know they're not uh they're just
random people who [ __ ] like you said
um you know and that's good like you
were born that's awesome but that
doesn't mean that you have any
obligations them necessarily so if they
suck
then you should totally totally not feel
bad
about cutting them out and like [ __ ]
make your own family man i'm just like
i'm a big advocate of that because i do
kind of feel like
a lot of people are messed up
because
they feel this weird like obligation
toward their parents because over there
they're from my that's my mom or that's
my dad or that's what you know even
though they're like the worst person
ever
please do not feel obligated i'm just
don't feel obligated it's only if you
got good yeah like i said i'm not saying
that from like because i like my parents
but
i've met enough people
that their parents were just awful yeah
like friends of mine and they're i'm
like why the [ __ ] are you even like
talking to these people still yeah like
you yeah they gave birth to you it's
like that's yeah about the extent of it
like why are you letting this like drag
your life down like please don't let
that like [ __ ] like cast a shadow of
your whole entire life because
um
three hours and 48 minutes it's time to
go this is time to go about you think oh
i'm starving yeah the food's cooking is
it what are you cooking in there great
bees
baking
sugar and all kinds of stuff do we have
anything other than that i got all kinds
of stuff don't worry about it
kind of stuff because that seems like
it's not well it's a side but i'm doing
i'm doing a bunch of it's just slowly
baking them oh it's a secret you're not
telling me yeah yeah i had this [ __ ]
[ __ ] prepped up earlier and i just
put it in there oh it's a secret yeah
it's at real low temperature it's just
nicole i don't even he doesn't even tell
me what he's cooking no i just have to
like no i just have to eat it
i like boston baked beans just put him
in a damn
bowl and put some sour cream on top
victor said put some grits in it no sour
cream oh that sounds good sour cream on
top okay oh yeah
they're sweet and spicy
i don't know i'm not i've never really
been into baked beans okay i'm just
saying
let's give you gas
yeah it's like i don't know i'm not into
beans in general
it's just starchy though it's just for
like a little bit okay let's go let's go
let's go ahead and shut it down we're
gonna talk all day we will talk all
[ __ ] damn tom's getting mad it's been
four hours tom's getting mad
we doing poke
it doesn't open there pookie she's
[ __ ] she thinks it opens in the
middle
like it's like sliding doors and she
thinks that she turns around like
she's begging okay what it doesn't open
in the middle you want to go in the
closet but you have to go on that end
though
look
she's like no that wasn't what i wanted
i was expecting something better she's
in there now
she's like oh yeah there's like [ __ ]
old staples and like [ __ ] soundproof
booth [ __ ] yeah uh all right yeah tammy
said my mom has chosen men over her
children yeah see it's like you don't
you don't have any obligation i'm just
saying right now you don't have any
obligation to don't put up with that
[ __ ] don't put up with like [ __ ]
just because they're related to you
doesn't mean you have to go out with
them i'm just saying you didn't choose
that
right yeah that's what i mean you didn't
choose that [ __ ] it's not your fault
don't worry about it
um victor says i still never had grits
out uh still have regrets victor go
ahead and sign off all night long all
night long you've been a contrary
[ __ ] go get some grits
put some cheese in it and some [ __ ]
bacon what you need to make some [ __ ]
grits hard-boiled eggs in there
he's hispanic his name is garcia and
then garcia man i've been eating
hispanic food growing up in brazil my
whole [ __ ] life and doing eating
hispanic [ __ ] you eat some [ __ ]
rednecks just see what [ __ ] see what
it's [ __ ] hardcore you don't have to
like it's great i do like grits but it's
it's just it's hot but you can't eat
them plain you can't complain
you want cheese it just tastes like
wallpaper want some real good cheese
salt pepper cheese
um bacon bits
um maybe some people like sugar but i'm
not tony sachery i'm not really into the
sugar sweet grits thing cajun seasoning
in it maybe
you know you'll see look up cajun grits
with cheese and bacon you'll see you'll
see the recipes you can get a whole
thing of [ __ ] grits it's kind of like
maseka you know the miseka tortilla
thing bag
it's like that but it's grits and it's
for like four or five bucks
and dude you could eat all that
not
no way [ __ ]
one cup of those grits makes a [ __ ]
thing of grits that big
yeah
yeah you can even put corn in it that'd
be good too
now that i think about it well you can
put whatever you wanted but yeah pretty
much there's all kinds of stuff you
could do with grits
like i said i kind of like them with
like a little bit of cheese and some
hard boiled eggs cheese hard-boiled eggs
whole arbitrary eggs just cooking
them and put them in there in your bowl
can i put it in a taco yeah um
no good it'd be messy
it's something you eat out of a bowl
it's like polenta
yeah anything you can do with like
polenta or a cream of wheat or anything
like that you could do with grits also
like i think we kind of talked about
that yeah uh i can only eat grits if
they have sugar in them i know some
people like really like i'm i'm not a
big sugar and grits fan but i know
there's like a whole like substitution
says it was a great show tonight it
seemed like a boring show to me but you
guys [ __ ] seem to love this [ __ ]
well you seemed like cranky and grouchy
no i can't congratulate you well i mean
you always kind of seem cranky you just
talk about like
that [ __ ] talk too much god damn [ __ ]
she's [ __ ] [ __ ] with me constantly
you watch youtube all day long
you do that
what do you want me to do you do though
what do you want me to do
i don't know
why i work all day i don't know what you
doing
yeah but you're also watching movies and
watching [ __ ] too i'm watching movies to
review yeah like i said i've been
watching uh
i've been watching [ __ ] handmaid's
tale because i got to do a show about
that
here's the thing i'm working too because
i'm cooking i'll [ __ ] vacuum in this
[ __ ] every now and then sweeping and
mopping everything taking care of the
[ __ ] don't listen to her
[ __ ] sweet who does laundry every
other day me yeah that's just good who
empties the dishwasher pretty much no i
did every day you did it today i did it
twice today you did it twice a day i've
done it uh pretty much every day for
five years or five six years now she
wants to fight over that it's [ __ ]
crazy dudes do things one or two times
and like they want a [ __ ] cookie for
it that's not true don't listen to her
that's no it's true it's
that's true she thinks that she's funny
tom's road raging maybe coveted brain
fog it might be it might be
have you got covid tom no
i'm giving a [ __ ] about code
you might get kobe yeah if i get it i'm
just going to give it to you aren't you
[ __ ]
hey i got vaccinated
i know you don't i don't give a [ __ ]
about it all right so
let's see we're almost there for it so
man [ __ ] i gotta pee again all right so
like are you gonna make some food other
than baked beans yeah no just yeah let
me handle it i handle it are you sure
yeah
considering he said the show was boring
tom sure contributed a lot of good
debate well yeah it's like i don't know
we always kind of i don't really know
how the show turns out until afterward
and i never watch them afterward i have
to say
i'd never watch them i'll i'll go back
and i'll watch them sometimes well you
do i never do
but you know what i mean because i got
like other [ __ ] to do i know how the
show goes yeah i know if it's a good
show or tom knows everything yeah you
know what i mean
and how the show goes tom knows
everything all right i understand i
understand show we
okay i understand i understand show yeah
that's another shirt yeah yeah i
understand show i understand um we'll be
back friday we're gonna be talking about
[ __ ] bigfoot [ __ ] finally
that's gonna be a good show
we're gonna have a good time with that
because man you better be talking [ __ ]
during that show
oh i you bet i will you bet i'm gonna be
talking about bigfoot
oh well you're gonna have slapped right
back
right in the tank you guys [ __ ] talk
[ __ ] about [ __ ] bigfoot
god damn goddamn i'll blame no no
bigfoot's a good topic it is a good
topic and i kind of feel like a lot of
people have been like asking us about it
like i said we did a cryptid show it was
fun but we kind of like spread it across
like several like i kind of picked like
a lot of weird cryptids because that was
like more fun all right i'm gonna go
ahead and i'm gonna go ahead and tease
this [ __ ]
okay
you guys know about my poultry guys to
my out-of-body experiences and
near-death experiences [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] totally totally legit
it was [ __ ] changed my life
because of that i was wondering well
what about all these ufos i was hearing
because this was back in the 80s but see
those are some those are many different
that's like different [ __ ] and then
another one's like well what about
bigfoot
what about loch ness monster
so i started studying all this as much
as i could pre-internet and then later
on in the internet era
to see exactly what was going on
and i would have thought that bigfoot
would have been more likely than
poltergeist
but it's weird that i saw poetry guys i
know exactly an out-of-body experience
and [ __ ] um near-death experiences i
guess it is but the thing about it is
that all paranormal things aren't
equally likely
no but you would think with a modern
just walking around type
intuition that oh yeah there's probably
a bigfoot ah there's no [ __ ] poultry
guys there's no out-of-body experiences
no i found quite the opposite and i
wouldn't have expected that
had i not had the experiences myself
um
and i was wondering like how weird is
that for out of body experiences poultry
guys to near-death experience and then
with stuart hamroff and those and those
other guys came out i was like oh yeah
okay that's probably why
it's called
stuart hameroff has something called the
quantum soul theory
and there's
um roger pembros who's uh
um
he's a physicist who
he has a nobel prize
and they've kind of
conferred saying that yeah
the mind is not a part of computation
it's not a product of computation of the
brain there's more to it there's quantum
entanglement involved in quantum
computation and those new quantum
computers are coming online soon
expensive as quantum computers and
they're going to be able to crack
everything
including all that crypto [ __ ]
they'll be able to get into that damn
[ __ ]
blockchain technology and [ __ ] [ __ ]
up they'll be [ __ ] up all your
cryptocurrencies and stuff
but uh when quantum computing comes
you're gonna have
robot intelligence real intelligence
it's very dangerous
very dangerous
because the brain is not digital it's
analog
and once you start having computers that
are analog man it [ __ ] changes the
game
just saying is that right i'm not
worried about it i'm worried about it
because me and you will be obsolete
i'm already obsolete yeah
they're gonna kill us off
okay right i'm really worried about it
[Laughter]
already insignificant i don't give a
[ __ ]
all right so i don't have anything to
lose but we're going to talk about
bigfoot lately i don't really care yeah
friday night there is look there is a
temptation for me i'm going to tell you
this i'm going to tell you [ __ ] this
me and my in the drunken state that i'm
in there's a temptation for me to
believe in bigfoot i want to believe in
big it would be cool there is a
possibility that there is a big cryptid
like that out there but as the [ __ ]
time goes on the probability of that
being real diminishes
just because we have so
i kind of feel like it'd be found by now
if it was well the sound maybe not maybe
satellite technology
i mean you could see deer on satellite
yeah it'd be cool if it was real i just
i just don't think it is
there may be an o-ring pending we'll see
we'll see we're going to talk more about
it
i know what's it
pat says i'm worried about it i'm not
worried about it like i said i'm not
i don't know like i said i'm already in
significance i don't really give a [ __ ]
insignificance doesn't scare me
so uh yeah so friday night we'll be back
talking about [ __ ] bigfoot sasquatch
whatever skunk ape maybe
boggy creek creature
we'll be talking about all that [ __ ] all
those cryptids
uh so yeah thanks for dropping by you
guys thanks for all your
super chats
hanging out with us on a wednesday night
we're gonna go eat something yeah we
will see you guys friday night
so have a good
time until then
we'll see you guys friday night
bye